- I wanna get better at pen spins again.
- I just do it with muscle memory now.
I don't even think about it.
I hold a pen and I just start doing it.
- I used to be able to do
that one and then the one
where you flick it and
then it goes back it back.
- And it goes back, yeah.
- Yeah. I can't do it anymore.
I can only do that one.
(pen clatters)
Fuck. (chuckles)
(laid-back music)
- How many like useless
skills have you ever learned
in your life?
- It's just my entire life.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
My entire life is a list of useful skills.
- Every video game ever.
- Yeah.
- Every video game ever. I think one day-
- What counts as a useful skill?
- I don't know.
- Like, okay, okay.
So, like the reason I learned pen spinning
is 'cause I fidget.
Like, I guess we just started,
but the reason I learned pen spinning
is because I just really like to fidget,
as you guys know.
- Yeah.
- So I thought to myself,
if I fidget all the time,
might as well make it look cool.
You know?
And that's literally the reason I learned
how to do the pen spin thing.
- I just did it 'cause
I was bored in class.
(Garnt laughing)
- Otherwise I'd probably
just like start chewing
on the pen or something, right?
(Joey laughing)
I don't know. I was like,
I was definitely that kid.
- What about like the people who like-
Felix does this with the knives.
- The knives?
- Yeah.
- I wanna-
- Well, you can't really bring
a knife to school, can you?
- Yeah.
- How do you even get into that?
- It's like, "Hey, teach."
- How do you learn and get into that
and then start doing it?
- I'd be way too scared to try.
- It's not about learning
or getting into that
'cause there's so many YouTube
channels that, you know,
teach that kind of stuff.
But it's having the commitment to be like,
I'm going to learn this now,
I'm going to spend time
learning this skill,
which I don't ever know if I'm gonna A,
you know, gonna be able
to use this in my life.
- Right.
Or again, what's a skill that's useful?
- Actually. Why did you learn
how to solve a Rubik's Cube?
- 'Cause I've always just wanted to.
- Really?
- 'Cause again,
you know, imagine you're
the only Asian kid
in a white school, right?
So, you're just like given
these like insane expectations
to do these like crazy skills, right?
Like people never believed me in school
when I said that I couldn't play chess
just 'cause they're like,
"But you're the Asian kid.
You're the smart kid.
You should know how to
do all these things.
Like you can't play
Shogi you can't play Go?"
I'm like, "No."
And it's like, fake Asian.
(Garnt laughing)
And so, and Rubik cubes
are a bit like stereotypically, right?
- Are they?
- Yeah.
- Are they though?
- Back when I was in school it was.
- By the way, welcome to Trash Taste.
We just jumped right into it.
- Welcome to another
episode of Trash Taste.
I'm Connor featuring the
boys, Garnt and Joey.
- Yeah.
- Me, the Rubik's Cube player.
- The Rubik's Cube kid.
- I don't know, and like I always like,
'cause it was one of
those things that I feel
you go to like any house.
- Right.
- And there's like a high possibility
that it's just kinda like sitting there
as like an ornament, right?
- Yeah.
- It was like very rare,
I'd say like out of 10 houses
that have a Rubik's Cube,
nine of them probably
have like a thin layer
of dust on top of 'em
'cause it's just like, oh,
it's just like a cool little knick-knack
to put on the shelf, right?
- Yeah.
- To make my-
It's like that coffee table book,
you know, that like no one
actually reads when it's like,
"Oh, you read this?"
And they're like, "Yeah.'
- It's like iconic.
- Yeah.
- I don't know. It's like a piece-
- Like how often do you get to flex
your Rubik's Cube skills?
If it's not like-
- Only on Trash Taste.
- If we didn't have like a
Trash Taste Rubik's Cube.
How many times in your life
have like you gone to a party
and you're like, "Oh my
God, it's a Rubik's Cube.
Guys, I'm about to flex."
- Step back.
- Step back, guys.
- Here comes the Asian kid.
- I think everyone who knows
how to solve a Rubik's Cube
says they don't regret it.
- No?
- No, they don't.
They've very (cross-talking).
- I guess it's like weirdly
an impressive skill to have.
- I promised them a video,
I was gonna learn it.
- It's not that hard. I actually
learned it once as well.
'Cause I learned it,
I've completely forgotten
it, but I remember like-
- Couldn't have been that
easy then? It's not that hard.
I forgot it.
- I learned it in a day.
- Yeah.
Because like I remember
I was in a hotel room
and I was staying in this
hotel and for some reason
it was like this, you know,
it was like this chic hotel,
they tried doing like different things
with their decorations and
it just had a Rubik's Cube
that was unsolved in this
like really clean hotel room.
- Right, right, right.
- And my like OCD mind was
just like, how dare they?
- It's not perfect.
- How dare-
It's like they fucking designed this room
to be like just mildly infuriating.
Just to like, it was a
perfectly clean room.
It looked amazing.
But on the desk there was
just a Rubik's Cube on there.
- It's like those memes of like,
you just see a picture and it's like,
what's wrong with this image?
- Yeah. (laughing)
Yeah, yeah, right.
And like I could not sleep
in this like hotel room
knowing that there was like-
I was just like staring all
night at this Rubik's Cube
that was just unsolved.
- Yeah.
- And so I just took a day
where I just Googled how
to solve a Rubik's Cube
so I could fucking just like solve it
before I went to bed, learn how to do it.
And it like, I never really
thought about how to solve
a Rubik's Cube before and I was like,
oh, it's actually pretty simple.
It's just an algorithm basically.
- Yeah. Right.
It's just a bunch of like algorithms.
- When you're following a
guide, it's pretty easy.
But the hard part is being able to do it
independently of a guide.
- So, I never got to the point
where it was just like
muscle memory, you know,
I was just like-
it was just like, you know,
it was a slow process,
but anyone's able to solve a Rubik's Cube.
- I also remember like
the reason why I actually
like finally learnt how to solve it.
'Cause I always wanted to solve it
since I was in high school, 'cause again,
I got, you know, called that kid.
But then, you know, pandemic hit,
everyone's stuck inside
and it's like, you know,
I think everyone had that
point where it's like,
well, I need to fucking
do something, right?
I can only play so many hours
of Animal Crossing per day, right?
So, it's like-
- There's only so many sourdough
breads that you can bake.
- Exactly, exactly. So,
I was like, all right,
well, let's like learn a
bunch of useless skills.
So, I think I learned how to
do like four or five different
useless skills and just Rubik's Cubes
just happened to be one.
- What were the other ones?
- The other one was, you know,
you've probably seen it before.
Do you know what kendama is?
It's like this very old Japanese toy
that it kind looks like
a hammer with a ball.
- Oh that one. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I did that as a kid, but
I wasn't very good at it.
- And what is that like?
- It's this like really
ancient Japanese toy,
kind of like, you know, like
spinning tops and stuff.
It's like that.
- What's the challenge?
- The challenge is you have to-
So, there's three different
plates on this like,
it looks like a hammer.
- Yeah.
- And there's like a concave
like plate on the bottom
and there's two concave plates on the side
and there's like a
little spike on the top.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The regular one,
yeah, that thing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The regular one is like,
you kind of turn it to the
side and you have to throw
the ball up without
actually holding the ball
and let it land in the cup.
- [Connor] Mm, yeah.
- That's just like the simple skill,
but there's like a million
different like tricks you can do.
It's kinda like yo-yoing, right?
Where it's like, you can just
like regularly do a yo-yo
and then there are yo-yo tricks, right?
Which are just like on another
level of difficult and skill.
- [Connor] Those are cool.
- And so like kendama is
kind of the same thing.
So, like Japan every year
has like these like kendama championships
where like you can
actually get like licenses
and like certificates to say
that you are a pro kendama
like player, if you do like
these certain tricks, right?
- That sounds cool.
- And one of the tricks,
I could do like the regular cup.
- Right.
- 'Cause like that's fucking easy.
Like anyone can do that, honestly.
One of the hardest ones is
where you have to get it
so that the ball lands on the spike.
- Right.
- By doing this.
- That sounds impossible.
- There's a trick to it.
But then I was like, I'm
gonna learn how to do that
during this pandemic.
- Yeah.
- So, I bought like a proper
like professional-graded,
like kendama because they have those.
There's like toy ones and then there's-
- Professional-graded.
- Yeah, there's like a kendama-
- This is a serious player.
- There's like a national
kendama committee in Japan
where they're like they
look at each kendama
and they're like, "Yeah,
you can use those in competitions."
And it comes with like a
certificate to be like, yeah,
this is a certified kendama.
- So, did you learn how to do?
- Yeah, I learned how to do it.
- Well, now you've gotta
bring it into the office.
I'm like curious now.
(Joey laughing)
- You can't say that.
They better be a video on screen
right now of Joey doing it.
- How have you never like posted a video
on Twitter or something?
- Because it's like the most
niche thing on the planet.
- I would like to see you.
- Okay?
- You just randomly like
in the next Anime Man
or Joey video, you just like have, well,
just casually do it.
Just don't explain yourself.
You just casually do it.
I swear to God, I swear to God,
every comment is going to be
about that one thing, right?
(Garnt laughing)
- I was gifted a Rubik's
Cube once as a kid.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- For Christmas.
- Oh, yeah.
- By my parents.
- Oh, okay.
- But it was a Harry Potter Rubik's Cube.
- Okay. (chuckling)
- So, all the tiles were themed.
They were all pictures of Harry Potter.
- [Joey] Right.
- 'Cause I loved Harry Potter.
Of course, I did, 'cause I'm British.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And so I have this cube, right?
And I'm thinking, wow, this is just great.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I turn it once.
Oh no, no, I'll put it back.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Don't wanna ruin the picture.
- I like the picture.
What's the point in the
cube if I (muttering).
(all laughing)
- That's me and basically
every Rubik's Cube before.
- So, you know, and then
another day I go back to it
and I turn it once, turn it
twice. And I'm like, no, no, no.
(Garnt laughing)
I can't, I don't want to ruin it.
And then one time I go, you know,
a few days later or
whatever, I love this cube.
It's the most awful thing.
Like it's so hard to solve
because the pictures are so shit.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- So, I start turning it
and I turn it like four or
five times and I'm like, okay,
I'm gonna start turning it back.
And then I turn it back.
I'm like one, okay.
Two, oh fuck.
It's not back the way it was.
- Yeah.
- And then I'm like, okay,
I think it's like just one,
there's one thing out of place.
I can fix this.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I start trying things and
I just keep fucking it up.
- [Garnt] It just gets worse and worse.
- And then I realized
what a shit toy this is.
I'm like eight years old.
I cannot solve this.
Now, I'm just fucked. (laughing)
And now if I wanna see the
picture of Harry Potter,
I have to actually like
learn how to solve it.
But I'm eight and I don't know how,
no one's even began to explain to me,
there's an algorithm.
Now, I Google, I get one
hour a day to go online.
I'm not using that.
I'm gonna go watch Yu-Gi-Oh!
GX, episode 400 part one
of three hours (cross-talking).
- Espanol.
- I'm gonna do that and not
look at the Rubik's Cube.
So, I was just like really disappointed
and I was really sad.
And I remember I found
it a few years later
and I thought, oh, I'll give it a shot.
And I just couldn't do it.
And then I just-
- That seems more difficult
than a regular one.
- It was.
'Cause the pictures were all like-
- Like low res?
- It was Harry Potter and it was Hogwarts.
So, they're all like brown.
(Joey laughing)
- Did you take like the stickers off?
- Yeah.
- Okay, okay. I was gonna ask that.
That's what I did as a kid.
- But then when I did
that, it wasn't, you know,
'cause this was the factory,
the factory production,
all the cubes were perfect.
So, when I started peeling them and shit
they were all like,
oh, a little bit wonky.
I couldn't get...
Stickers are some of
the most annoying shit
to like place.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- 'Cause you put it and you're like,
I'm doing it perfectly flat.
You put it on. Doosh.
I don't know how that happens.
- Every time.
- Don't wanna get gum clumpy like.
- Yeah, right. (chuckles)
- Yeah, exactly.
You're like, fuck it. (heavy breathing)
- It's like that, but
(cross-talking) (Garnt laughing)
- Yeah. Right?
- Yeah, I mean,
like I think the only like
useless skill I've learned
before was, I mean, do you
guys know how to juggle?
- I learned how to do the one handed.
- Learned how to do the one handed juggle?
- Yeah.
But like, you know, with two
balls where you kind of like-
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I never got to the point
where it was with three.
- Yeah, I mean, growing
up in Brighton Beach,
I remember like one day I
just decided to just learn
how to juggle using pebbles and stuff.
- Yeah.
- And I think I can still juggle. I dunno.
I dunno, I dunno. It has been a while.
- We have to have a video
where we show each other
the useless skills we learned.
- Actually, the most useful party trick,
do you guys have any party tricks
that you like can show off
in a party or whatever?
- Not that I remember.
- I'm like fucking Susan
Boyle, every party I go to,
just everyone stops.
- Actually, like the
most useful party trick
I know is just being able to
open a bottle with anything.
- [Connor] Oh yeah.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like I've done that a few times.
'Cause it's not just like-
Every time you do it, if
you wanna just know a trick
that will take you five minutes to learn,
but will be useful in basically
every party you go to.
- Yeah.
- Just learn how to open
a bottle with a lighter
or another bottle.
- I feel like us not
sharing these abilities
is like making this episode worse.
What's the point of us filming this?
- No-one believes us.
- What's point of us filming this?
- Like how often do you go to a party
and you see a Rubik's Cube there
and you're like, finally.
- Like boys, step back.
- Boys, my time to shine.
- I can click my wrists on command.
- Can you?
- Yeah, I can.
(wrists clicking)
- Urgh.
- Oh, that doesn't sound healthy.
- [Garnt] Ah.
You got like a 80-year-old wrist.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Is that the gamer wrist?
- That's the gamer wrist.
(all laughing)
- You wanna see these scars, boys?
- Tell me you have carpal tunnel.
Say you have carpal tunnel.
- I can just click both of them.
- Yeah. I only know like
small little things that will,
you know, maybe impress like
your five-year-old cousin.
- Yeah.
- You know,
when you're at home,
like I can do like the
water droplet sound,
like that's the only thing I can do.
- Oh yeah.
You can do the Skype thing perfectly.
- The Skype thing?
- The Skype...
(Joey singing the Skype ring theme)
(all laughing)
- [Joey] Is that a skill?
- We just like ran out
of shit to talk about.
Like, Oh, what'd you do?
Joey do that thing again.
(Joey sings the Skype ring theme)
- I think that's really
funny. (all laughing)
- Yeah, it is.
- We're talking about useless skills.
- That appeals to a very
like tight niche, you know,
like you have to be on the
internet in the mid 2000s
to appreciate that one.
- Can you do the Windows
XP shutdown noise?
(all chuckling)
Can you do that?
(Joey singing the Windows shutdown notes)
(all laughing)
That's not accurate at all.
That's just me singing it.
(all laughing)
- Shit.
- I've never done that.
Why did you think I could do that?
- I've always been able to
do that thing where you like
hold your body up.
I don't know why I've
always been able to do that.
- Oh, what do you mean?
- Oh, the one that's like
through here, like that?
- Like when you're just like on a surface
and you can like hold your whole body.
- Oh, you mean like what
break dancers do, kind of?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. I've
always been able to do that.
I don't know why.
- Yeah. You have to have like
good core strength for that.
Don't you?
I guess you got great
core strength, right?
- I dunno. Maybe I do.
I don't know if (mutters).
- This like conversation
has just reminded me
that I like I went through like a phase,
like, you know, you're a kid
and sometimes you go
through phases, right?
So, I remember the first
time I ever saw David Blaine
on TV doing street magic.
And I'm just like, I want to do that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That looks incredible.
And I remember like
going through this phase
where I, you know, there
was these packages,
this was before you could
just Google or YouTube
how to do magic tricks online.
So, I actually had to
like pay, like send off,
I had to convince my
parents to send off money
to this company that like
supposedly sent you magic tricks
and like magic secrets and all that.
- That just sounds like a
scam. (Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I'm like, I'm surprised
like for the one time
in my life, it wasn't a scam.
- Oh, wow.
- They actually like
sent me back like a VHS
that I-
- Oh shit.
- Like played.
And I remember like learning
how to do like a bunch
of these magic tricks.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I'm just like, great.
I'm gonna impress everyone around me.
But like there's never a moment
where you go to a party or
you go to a family gathering
and like, you don't wanna be
that guy who just brings out
a deck of cards.
- Hey ya, pick a card.
Pick a card, any card.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah.
- It's just like, you know, I know magic.
I have have a deck of cards
on me right now, you know.
You don't wanna be that guy.
So, I've never been able to like,
even though I learned how to
use these skills as a kid,
I never was able to show them off.
So, I mean, it's kinda like
martial arts in some way, right?
Because, you know, talking to-
I remember seeing this YouTube video about
like why do people learn martial arts?
'Cause you basically
spend years of your life.
You spend years and years
honing this one skill
for like these moments that will only last
maybe like a few minutes
of your life, right?
Unless you go to tournaments
and stuff like that, right?
'Cause like you're training yourself
for like that one fight
you're gonna be in,
in like whatever moment
that's going to be, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- But then you spend years
building up to that moment,
and like what if you just
fuck up in that moment, right?
What if all the training
just leaves your body
in that one moment?
- What if the dude's like nine foot?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I didn't try out for this.
- I'm like fuck, dude.
What weight are are you again?
Oh shit.
That's my weight class.
- Yeah.
(Connor laughing) I feel like
that's the good thing though
about like doing YouTube
is that like, for me,
I just use videos to do shit
that I otherwise wouldn't normally do.
So, like with like martial
arts, for instance,
like I remember, oh my God.
I don't even remember how
many years ago this was,
this is like a four or
five year old video.
I learned how to like backflip in a video.
- I was going to say,
if there's one skill,
I want to learn how to do
actually, it's the backflip.
- What? Just like standing?
- Yeah. Just standing
- A standing backflip.
- You did a standing backflip?
- I did a standing backflip
once in a video. (chuckling)
It was me and like-
- What did your parents encourage you?
They're trying to get rid
of you? Like. (laughs)
- No, no, I was in Japan already.
- [Connor] Oh, okay.
- I was in Japan and it was
me, Dogan and my friend Al.
- But you were above the
age of like 15 doing this?
- Yeah. This was like
four years ago. (chuckles)
- Oh my God. That's like suicide.
- Yeah. And we, yeah, because we cosplayed
as Naruto characters. (chuckles)
- Oh my God. (laughs)
That's the reason you
learn how to backflip
'cause of Naruto?
- 'Cause there was a
Naruto online sponsorship.
- Oh my God. (laughing)
- And I was like, well,
I need to do something Naruto-related.
You know what? I'll learn ninja tricks.
And by ninja tricks,
I mean just tricking and
learning how to backflip.
- Okay, so how long did I
used to learn how to backflip?
- [Joey] Like I think we were in that gym
for maybe like five, six hours.
- Okay.
- But I learned how to do like
other tricking, like tricks.
'Cause like Dogan used
to be like a fucking
like professional trickster.
Is that the right word? I dunno.
- Professional trickster.
- Sounds like a Persona character.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- What like hard-core?
- Yeah, yeah.
He used to do like tricking.
- What the fuck?
- Are you serious.
- And then he like hurt his
knees, I think really badly.
And he like couldn't stop doing it.
But he taught me how to
like backflip and shit.
And I did it successfully once.
- Yeah.
- And I haven't done it since.
- Do you think you'd be able to relearn
and pull off another backflip?
- Maybe.
Because I think what took me so long
and I think what the level of entry is
is that you just have
to get over your fear.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what like, 'cause
I've seen people trying
to learn backflips.
So, I'm just like,
that looks like a really
interesting process.
- You just snapped your
neck, just get over it.
Get over the fear, you piece of shit.
- Yeah, because like it's not natural
for you to be like, all right,
jump and also pull your entire body back
like this at the same, like
your body's just like, no.
Don't do that.
- I think that's cool.
But the one skill I learned,
I also love this channel.
It's Mike Boyd.
Yeah, he just like
how long can it take me to learn X thing?
- Oh, I think I know that
ca- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I think I've seen that.
- He's got this one video
and I really wanna learn
how to do this.
He has an umbrella and
he's holding the umbrella
and the trick is is that
he throws the umbrella
in front of him.
It goes like quite far away.
And then it opens in midair
and while he's walking,
he catches the umbrella as he's like-
So, it fully opens-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it floats down and he catches it.
- Yeah.
- And I want to learn how to do that.
- There's so many like
little tricks like that
I wanna learn how to do.
- So, imagine you're on
like the Japanese street
and you're just like,
(Connor makes whooshing noise)
all right.
(Joey laughing)
It's like some anime shit.
- I wanna do that with like a cap
where like you throw the cap
and it lands perfectly on your head.
- But then that's not good enough.
'Cause you're always gonna
like pull it down, right?
With the umbrella it's like immediate.
You're like walking, you're good to go.
No readjustment.
You've got the umbrella.
- Oh no. You know, what's
a truly useless skill
I've always wanted to learn?
- What?
- Is to draw a perfect hand circle.
- Oh yeah. I've seen that. Yeah.
- 'Cause I've seen so many
videos and every time I see it,
I'm just like, not,
that is the most satisfying
thing in the world.
Just like free=hand. Just like, whoosh.
- That one video when
the guy like does that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The guy does that.
- I wanna do that shit.
Yeah, that's a cool party trick.
- That is a cool party
trick. Everyone has a pencil.
Not everyone has a Rubik's Cube, you know?
- Exactly. Exactly.
- I don't carry a pencil
on me all the time.
- Well, no, if you're at someone's house.
- Oh, yeah.
- You're not gonna be in a house
that doesn't have a drawing
equipment of some kind. Have
you ever been in a house
where they just don't
have any pens and pencils?
- I think that's my house (mumbles).
- [Garnt] That's just
Connor's house, right?
- I think that's my house.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- True millennial right here.
- What's pencil?
What's pen and paper, dude?
- Actually. I don't think I
have a pencil in my house.
- What?
- I have pens.
- No, there's no way,
you guys live in Japan.
There's more paperwork
than fucking anything.
- Yeah, pencils, pens-
- Yeah, we just use pens.
- Well, yeah, pens, that's what
I mean like drawing things.
- Yeah, I guess like
now that I'm thinking-
- Drawing equipment.
- Drawing things.
- What's the word?
- Are you calling pens-
- Drawing things.
- It's drawing things.
- What is it called?
(Connor chuckling)
- What are those painters paint with?
Oh, yeah, they're drawing things.
- Fortunately I don't
draw anything. (laughing)
When was the last time I drawed something?
- Like the sad music playing.
I haven't drawn anything
since the accident.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I haven't drawn anything.
- I just have like zero skill in drawing
and I have done for my entire
life, I think, I don't know.
- We need to do like a
drawing competition now,
but just a-
- I'm somebody who also sucks at drawing,
I believe it's like singing.
I don't think you're
just like naturally good
like immediately, oh,
maybe you are actually.
- I think some people are.
- Some people are.
- I think you do have to practice though.
- Yeah, of course you have to practice.
But I think the last
time I drew something,
I can't remember what the context was,
but I think I had to
draw a cat for something.
(Joey sniggering)
Oh, it was the Netflix shoe.
I remember 'cause it was
for Anime Club and Netflix
and I had to draw a cat on
the whiteboard or something.
(Joey laughing)
And, Joey just made like,
Joey, I was drawing this cat
and Joey could not recognize
like that was even an
animal that I was drawing
on this whiteboard. (laughing)
- He drew like a UMA.
Like I dunno what it was.
It was like it was not of this earth.
- What's a UMA?
- Like those like
unidentified, what is it?
Like the chupacabra.
Like that level.
It's like urban legend shit.
- Chupacabra?
- What the fuck's a UMA?
(Ashley speaking)
Something animal.
- This is the first time I've ever-
- [Ashley] Unidentified mysterious animal.
- Unidentified mysterious animal, yeah.
- This is the first time.
- Like UFO.
- This is the first
fucking thing I've ever-
- You know, like Mothman
or like chupacabra,
like any of those urban legends.
- I didn't know they were called UMAs.
- UMAs, unidentified mysterious animal.
- Do you believe any of those?
- No, no.
Although when I was 10,
I did believe chupacabra.
But I think anyone-
- Why would you believe in chupacabra?
- Because you're 10 years old.
(Connor laughing)
You believe Harry Potter is
real when you're 10 years old.
- Isn't that like Mexican or something?
- Yeah, it was Mexican or Spanish.
I mean, chupacabra means
goat drinker or some shit,
I don't know.
- Well, what is the chupacabra?
- I don't fucking know.
- I killed it in Red Days, I killed it,
I killed it in Red Days.
- It was this like viral video
in like early 2000s, I think.
Where like there was this,
it was Mexico or Spain or somewhere,
it was some Spanish speaking country,
where like just some dudes
went into a forest at night
'cause they heard some shit.
And then there was this like creature
that appeared on camera.
- It was like the goat person, right?
- Yeah. Yeah, it was like eating a goat
or it looked like a demonic goat.
And like I remember like back then,
like it was a huge sensation,
especially in Japan.
It was a massive sensation
because for an early
2000s video, it was like
way too high quality.
Like it looked way too real.
Like you look at the
chupacabra videos now,
and you're like, oh,
that could almost like,
if you weren't aware of it,
that could almost come off as convincing.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it was like too good.
And then people were like
shocked when they found out
it was fake and it's like,
oh, who would've thought
there isn't a fucking
goat drinker demon thing
in the forest of Mexico, or
whatever the fuck it was.
- Yeah. I think like the only
thing that I believed as a kid
or I wanted to believe,
I really wanted to believe
like the Lochness Monster.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I don't know, 'cause a kid,
you just obsessed with
dinosaurs and you're like-
- Exactly.
- You like stories.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- You like thinking cool
shit exists out there
But it doesn't.
- It's like everyone, you know,
everyone wanted to believe
Moby Dick was a real thing.
- Like Bigfoot, like a lot of people,
weirdly a lot of people really-
- That fucking image of
Bigfoot, like doing this.
- People like really believe
Bigfoot for some reason.
- But like it also like makes me think,
what if one of those
things was real, right?
What would make you actually
believe it, right? Because-
- Seeing it.
- If I, yeah, if I see it, like, yeah.
If I see like a news
article of like scientists
like properly talking about it.
- Having someone credible
be like, yep, this is legit.
- Because like I remember, because I think
we have talked about this
before, but like, I mean,
it's been proven by the
government that UFOs exist.
- Yeah.
- And like nobody
freaked out over it.
Nobody really reacted to it.
- Besides Alex Jones.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Well, yeah.
- I mean like, yeah, last year with the,
what was it the black files?
- Yeah.
- But, yeah, like it's like,
if I said to you, "Oh,
by the way we found an alien spaceship,
we know it's an alien, by the
way." You'd be freaking out.
But if you're like, "Oh,
we have no fucking clue
what that thing was."
You're like-
- [Joey] It could've been like a drone.
- Oh, oh, yeah.
- [Joey] Or something.
- Everyone like doesn't,
'cause you're like, oh,
well, I'm sure there's
an explanation for it.
We just don't know.
But if it's like,
by the way we literally found
the things from Men in Black,
then I think everyone's
gonna be like, what the fuck?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. I mean like, 'cause
I mean it's weird, right?
'Cause you do look at the videos.
I do look at the videos of the UFO images
and the UFO videos and I'm just like,
that's freaky and I do think UFOs exist,
but do I think it's aliens?
I don't know.
I dunno myself.
I dunno how to react to it, I guess.
- [Connor] Oh, go on.
- No, I was gonna say like
there was a weird part
of me that saw those
like government file, you know, videos,
which are like, you know, legit, right?
'Cause why would a
organization like that lie?
- Yeah.
- But it's like, I saw it and
I was like, why does that look
like just every other
UFO video I've ever seen?
- I think that's the
problem with it, right?
Because there's so many fakes nowadays
that even when the real
thing is actually released,
you're so desensitized with it.
You're just like-
- It's like the fake ones
looked more real than this one.
- Yeah. Right, right.
- Like why is that?
- It's just I thought
seeing UFOs, real UFOs,
would be more impressive.
- Yeah.
- And I dunno why I thought that,
but I just thought it
would be more impressive.
And it didn't just wasn't, you know.
- I mean, I assume that if
an alien species finds us,
we'll probably be dead.
(Joey laughing)
- Why? They'll just wipe us out?
- Odds are, think of it.
If an alien spaceship,
if an alien civilization
had the opportunity to,
or had the capability
of finding other planets
and going around scouting.
- [Joey] Mm.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- They're more technologically
advanced than us.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- We're pretty fucked.
- Odds are they're not gonna
wanna be like, hey, friends.
And they're gonna be like,
let's take all your stuff.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You have minerals. We need them.
Collect the minerals.
(all laughing)
- You require more minerals.
- Like fucking StarCraft.
They're just gonna use us
for another (indistinct).
Why would they give a shit?
They're not gonna give a fuck.
And they'll treat us like cows.
- Yeah, true, true.
- I mean, it's like, it's kind of,
I agree with you because I think,
what if humanity had this capability?
- We would fuck over everyone.
- Yeah. We would, we would.
- We would fuck everyone.
- Yeah, we fuck ourselves over enough.
Like let alone another species.
- We can't even save
our own fucking planet,
let alone some other
species planet, you know?
- Anyone who thinks that like,
we wouldn't just blow up a planet,
if we just thought they were
a little strange looking,
they just like that doesn't
have enough understanding
of human (cross-talking).
- Especially if they have
like natural resources
or some shit.
- Yeah.
- I'm sure a lot of people would be like,
I don't think we should do this,
but the government of whatever,
the United government of all, whatever,
would be like bye bye, bye bye planet.
- Yeah.
- Bye bye, bye bye.
- We'll just find another one.
- But they are rich in
iron, we must destroy.
- Exactly. Right?
- Yeah.
Which, speaking of destroying planets
and living through the
apocalypse, I guess,
we kind of-
- What a fantastic segue.
- Yeah. What a fantastic segue.
We kind of lived through
something like that yesterday.
Didn't we?
- Yeah.
That was terrifying. We
had a very big earthquake.
- I was like what you referring to?
- Oh, I knew immediately
what he was on about.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because you had a very
different experience to us.
- Same brain cell.
- Yeah, we have
the same brain cell.
- Yeah, we had two big
earthquakes actually
yesterday back-to-back.
I'm sure the world news has covered it.
It's probably old news by the
time you're watching this.
But-
- I mean, it was the biggest earthquake
I have lived through so far.
I think.
It was bigger than the one in LA
or at least it felt like it
was bigger than the one in LA.
- I think Tokyo was like mag 4 or 5.
- 4, 4.5, I think.
- Yeah.
But I think it was like magnitude 7.3.
- The epicenter.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and Fukushima.
- But yeah. I mean,
I thought I'd experienced
like big earthquakes in Japan before.
And this one, like even for
people who have lived here,
lived in Japan for longer than me
said that this was the biggest one
that they've experienced as well.
- Yeah.
- And you know, it's a lot of people said,
it's the biggest one
that they've experienced
since the 2011 earthquake.
- Yeah.
- In Fukushima as well, right?
- Yeah. Because I think it was
because it wasn't just one.
- Yeah.
- It was like one that
was pretty big already.
That caused another even bigger one
like literally two minutes later.
- Yeah.
- So, it just felt like one
continuously large earthquake.
- Well, how was it for you guys?
- Am I weird? I like earthquakes.
- [Joey] You like earthquakes?
- I quite like it. Is that bad?
- Like in what sense?
- I feel like a fun, quick
time event or something.
I don't know.
'Cause, I dunno why,
but it feels kind of fun.
(Garnt laughing)
Is this weird?
- Yeah, it's a bit.
- I know this is weird.
- Yeah.
- I dunno.
- And it is technically
a natural disaster.
- Yeah.
- I know.
I know, I know.
Because it's like it causes
so many problems, but like-
- That's like watching a bush fire
and being like, "Sick!"
- You know like I get it.
I get it.
- Well, you don't say
that about like typhoons.
- This is the guy who gave
us shit for looking at fire.
Like so a canister and here he is
being like looking at an earthquake.
- Like, wee!
- Like a disaster on like
10 times the magnitude.
No more, like thousands of times
the magnitude of an exploding can.
And he's just like, "Ooh,
a quick time in bed."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- It's just, I dunno.
- The bayonet of music starts playing.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I obviously protect whatever
is valuable in my house.
But also it's kinda of interesting seeing
what stays and what falls over.
I quite enjoy that.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I understand-
- Taking bets, being like that.
- I kinda, yeah.
Well, I was out and I was
kind of like hyped to think
like when I came back I was like, ooh,
I wonder what fell over?
Like nothing had fell over.
And I was like-
- And you were disappointed?
- I'm like, oh, okay.
Obviously if like my TV had fell over,
I'd be like, fuck, that's shit.
But you know when it's mild ones,
like obviously 'cause
it was a big earthquake,
but it wasn't that big in Tokyo.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I like those ones,
but obviously if it was like 8,
that'd be like, I'd be
another thing entirely.
- [Garnt] Well, yeah, yeah.
- I do not like this one. I
do not like this earthquake.
- I mean like one thing
I do not understand
after having lived in
Japan and experienced
a bunch of earthquakes now is,
when do they send out
the earthquake alarm?
- [Connor] I do not get it.
- Like I swear to God-
- It's when the epicenter is close enough.
- Oh, okay.
- Did you get one?
- [Joey] No.
- [Garnt] No.
- I have never gotten one
since I got my new phone.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- I've definitely gotten a bunch,
but it's only when the
epicenter is close enough
to where you live,
where it sets it off?
Because it was in Fukushima and Miyagi,
it was like too far away.
- Right.
- But the earthquake was
big enough to the fact
that we felt it.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Because I hear the earthquake alarm
and I brace myself and it's
like the piddliest, piddliest
like little earthquake I've ever felt.
- Yeah.
- Like out of nowhere, like yesterday,
you get like the entire
fucking house starts shaking.
I'm like, why didn't I
get an alarm for this?
I feel like this is like more
prevalent for like the alarm
that I should be bracing myself for.
(Joey laughing)
- I do. Have you watched
that YouTube video
that's like noises that
will give you anxiety
if you live in Japan or something.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- And it's like all the disaster noises.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Have you heard the tsunami one?
- Yeah. The tsunami one was terrifying.
- It's horrible, it's like the,
what's the tower in Pokemon called?
- Oh, the fucking Pokemon Tower.
- Like that, no, the one with the dead-
- Yeah, Pokemon Towers.
- It's just Pokemon Towers?
- I think, no, Lavender Tower.
- Lavender Tower.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's like that level of
creepy, the tsunami one.
(Joey singing)
This episode is sponsored by Honey.
We all shop online.
Right, guys?
Guys?
Anyone?
And we've all seen that promo
code taunt us at the checkout.
But thanks to Honey, manually
searching for coupon codes
is a thing of the past.
Honey is a free browser
extension that scours the entire
internet for the best
promo code that you can use
and applies it automatically for you.
Honey supports over 30,000 stores online
that ranges from tech
companies to gaming products,
to fashion brands and even food.
Here's how it works.
Just imagine you're shopping
at one of your favorite stores online.
Don't tell me, don't tell me,
I'm gonna guess.
Jesus Christ, that's what you're into?
And then when you're at the checkout,
so the Honey button drops down
and all you have to do
is click apply coupons,
wait a few seconds as Honey searches
for all the available coupons
it can find for that site.
And then if it finds a working coupon,
you'll watch as the prices drop.
I've been getting ready
to fly back to England.
And recently Honey saved me
$10 on this new travel bag
I got just for that.
If you don't already have Honey,
you can be straight up
missing out on free savings.
It's literally free and
installs in a few seconds.
And by doing it, you'll
be doing yourself a favor
and helping us out too.
So, get Honey for free today
at joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
Thank you to Honey for
sponsoring this episode,
back to the video.
(man speaking in foreign language)
(bells chiming)
- Oh, that's it.
- I fucking hate that.
It's horrible.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That one's horrible, dude.
- [Joey] That one.
(Connor singing)
It sounds like when you get
an item in an (indistinct).
- It sounds like I just opened
a box in Zelda or something.
(Joey singing)
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
(Connor singing)
- I think it's creepy because like-
- It's slightly dissonant.
- Yeah.
And it feels like you're in a
room that is like collapsing.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah.
- Like it's designed to do that
and it's like, you're dying.
- It's like you're in a game
and you just like triggered a bad event.
- No, no, no.
I know the feeling.
Have you ever heard
like those music remixes
where they take a happy
song and they remix
it in like a minor key?
That's exactly what it sounds like.
- You talking about like
"Wrecking Ball" in G minor.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. (laughing)
Joey gets what I mean.
Joey gets the music memes.
- Music memes.
- Like Joey gets the music memes.
- Yeah, something in G minor.
- Yeah, yeah, that feels dirty.
Oh, I don't like that feeling.
- Yeah, yeah. It's demonic.
- Yeah, yeah.
The one that always
gives me fucking anxiety
is the earthquake alarms.
- Yeah.
(Joey mimicking earthquake alarm)
- But that one feels dangerous.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- The tsunami one is creepy
'cause it doesn't feel like it's,
it's like, oh my God,
this is like a world ending event.
- Yeah.
It just sounds like a minor discomfort.
- [Connor] Yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- It's like the malls
closing. Dring, dring.
Dring, dring.
- [Connor] Get out of the mall now.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, I mean, like for the
earthquake yesterday for me,
so it was actually big enough
that it knocked out the power
in my section of Tokyo.
- Did you just dox yourself, Garnt?
- [Garnt] Sorry?
- Did you just dox yourself?
- Well, it was like the
path of power got outed
in a bunch of facilities in Tokyo.
- I think the news said it
was like 2 million homes
were out of power.
- Yeah.
- I didn't even know if mine,
I might've lost power,
but I was out so.
- But you definitely would've
known if you lost power.
- I wasn't there, you see?
- Oh, okay.
You weren't at home. Okay, okay.
- I could've gone out.
- Mine was fine.
Yeah.
I mean, like, I actually
didn't even feel the first one.
I dunno, like sometimes
people were just like, "Oh,
there was an earthquake." And
I'm like, "I didn't feel it.
Was there really an earthquake?
Or did you just stand up too fast?
Just got a head rush."
You know, 'cause that happens
to me sometimes, you know,
where I think it's an
earthquake happening,
but it's really just-
- Just me tripping balls.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I just feel like a little lightheaded.
- Are you watching
something in Dolby Atmos?
I genuinely think there's
always an earthquake happening
when I'm watching Dolby Atmos.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Well, like the THX starts.
It's like (trilling).
- Dude, like, the floor
shakes with the Dolby,
I'm always like, "Oh shit, are we?"
- Yeah.
So, I was actually in
my office on the bottom,
on the ground floor.
'Cause I live in a house
and Sydney was chilling on the bed
on the third floor of our house.
And I just hear Sydney
going, "Garnt, Garnt, Garnt!"
And I'm just like, I didn't know
it was an earthquake going on.
So, I was just like
taking my time with her.
Let me finish this piece of work.
And I'll just like
casually stroll upstairs.
And I see Sydney, like
just looking shell-shocked.
'Cause Sydney's like really
sensitive to like earthquakes
and like natural disaster kind of thing.
So, she's just like, (heavy breathing)
"Did you feel that, did you feel that?"
And I was like, "What?
What's going on, Sydney?"
"That was an earthquake,
Garnt. That was an earthquake."
And I was like, "Was there?
Are you sure, Sydney? Are you sure?"
And like 'cause I didn't feel it at all.
- Right. Yeah, yeah.
- I didn't feel that at all.
And so I, you know, I was
like about to check my phone
to see if, you know, anyone
else had posted about it
or anything like that.
And then just as I got out my phone,
it like the second quake
hit, the second quake.
- The bigger one.
And it's like, you know, this one,
it didn't like immediately
start off strong for me.
It like shook a little bit.
It shook a little bit.
And so it started shaking.
I was like, "Oh, that's an earthquake."
And Sydney was like, "Huh?
Yeah, you feel it now, you son of a bitch.
You feel it now?
You feel it fucking now?"
And then as she finished that,
our lights just like turn off.
- Right.
- And there was just
an immediate 180 from,
"Oh, (heavy breathing)
no, no, no, come here,
come here, please.
Come here, come here."
(all laughing)
- Where are you?
- All it took was the lights going out.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, I mean like it was
actually like pretty surreal
for me because
it was the first time.
I mean, in Thailand we're like, fuck,
I'm fucking used to power outages.
We have like plenty of lights
and everything like that.
In here, it was just so surreal
seeing just my entire block,
basically, my entire town,
just like in complete darkness.
- Yeah.
- I think I posted
a video of me just like walking around
outside my house.
I have never seen my street
almost in complete darkness.
This is freaky as hell.
Which, because it was the first time
I'd just seen any side of Tokyo,
just completely dark with
some emergency lights on.
It was like, it was
kind of surreal, right?
- Like apocalyptic.
- Yeah, kind of apocalyptic, right?
So like, 'cause I thought,
why not just take a walk just to see,
just to see what the city is like.
- Take it in.
- Yeah.
Just to see what the city is like
when we're going through
a disaster like this.
- Yeah.
- And I think
the first time it hit me of
just how surreal this was
was I walk out and, you
know, Tokyo was dark,
but the point it actually
hit me was when I walked
to my main road and I
could see the Lawsons
had its lights out, and
I'm just like, holy shit.
Even the combini is affected.
- That never happens.
- This is the first time I've ever seen
the fucking combini just out.
And like the employees are
in there just like fucking,
they couldn't even open the
door because like the power
for like the automatic door wasn't open.
I was like, oh, this is real.
I dunno why it was the combini
just 'cause like I thought no matter what,
like a comet could be
crashing and like Lawsons
would still be like serving.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Because like even when Japan
has like the worst typhoon
in like the past 10 years,
which I think it did like
last year or the year before.
- Two years ago.
- The only thing that
was open, the Lawson.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- The combini's, right?
- The combini's are all open.
- Through thick and thin.
- Yep.
- So, that was the first time.
Yeah, that was the first
time it was surreal for me
because it was also surreal
just seeing which parts
of the grid were still supported.
- Mm.
- So, actually like, 'cause
I had to walk around.
So, like it was some
traffic lights were working
and some weren't.
So, that was weird.
- Wow, traffic lights weren't working?
- Yeah. Some of the traffic
lights weren't working, right?
But I think they must have prioritized
the more busier intersections, right?
Because all like the big
intersections were working,
but some of the smaller ones-
- Oh, all right.
- Weren't working.
- Oh, I always thought that
the road lights and stuff
are on a separate thing
entirely from the normal-
- Well, they might have
like a backup system.
- Yeah. They normally do.
'Cause obviously the last
thing you want is no-
- No traffic lights.
- Yeah, and there was
actually a traffic accident
like near where-
- That's not surprising at all.
- Yeah.
- Near where I was,
I think might have been because of that.
But like the only thing
that was actually lit
was the train stations actually.
The train stations had everything working.
The elevators were still
working and everything,
even though everything
else was like pitch black.
- It wasn't the only
thing that was like on.
I was having a great time in Akihabara.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
I was having a whale of a
time. I was in the basement.
- [Joey] Right.
- In some anime song bar,
went in there and there's
a bunch of Japanese men
singing Macros songs.
- Nice.
- With a bunch of very
young looking girls.
- Oh.
- Okay.
- So, we went in there and we
were just having a good time.
I sang-
- You were like, "Man, I'm
fucking lighting this place
on fire, man." (laughing)
- I was singing, "Colors."
(Connor sings and laughs)
- Everyone clapped. (clapping)
- Must have thought like the base
of your voice was just like so strong
that it was shaking the entire building.
- I did "JoJo" as well.
So, I- (Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, I bet everyone
in the bar was like,
"Oh, they got Dolby Atmos here."
(all laughing)
Holy shit.
- It was so funny.
When it came,
I was with the guys that I
did the wrestling video with.
He was like, "Oh, there was
an earthquake just now."
I was like, "Ah, I didn't know."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Then 10 seconds later,
the second one that was bigger,
started like shaking.
And we were all like, "Yeah, whoa."
(all laughing)
'Cause everyone was drunk.
- Jo!
- JoJo!
Yeah, yeah.
And then, yeah, but we were in
the basement, it was shaking.
But it wasn't like that bad.
So, like that's why,
initially, I was quite shocked
when I was getting
texts, a bunch of texts,
people being like, sorry that scared me.
I was like ghost, ghost.
- Earthquake, earthquake.
- That's why I was quite shocked
when I was getting so many texts
and people being like,
"Oh my God, are you okay?
Are you okay?" What, what, what?
- Well, weirdly enough you don't feel it
when you're underground.
You feel it when you're really up higher.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And you feel it more at least.
- Yeah. You feel it way
more when you're up high.
- Yeah, it was all right. It was good.
Did you get a lot of people
who don't live in Japan?
- Who don't?
- Who aren't used to
earthquakes messaging you.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- Oh my gosh. Are you okay?
- After the round of like
people living in Japan tweets
that I saw, I started to get
like 17 messages from people
all over the world.
'Cause once it hit the mainstream, like,
you know, international news.
- Yeah.
- It's weird, 'cause it's like, I get it.
'Cause like how could you
know the severity of it?
But I think if I'm tweeting
about it, it's probably-
- It probably means I'm okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
Everybody's, oh, all right.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean like I think it's worse
for like someone like Chris, right?
'Cause he was living right next to it.
Like I can't imagine how strong
the earthquake was for him.
- Yeah, it hit really hard with him.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
'Cause I've never been in an earthquake
where a lot of stuff has
literally like just like gone
on the floor and started smashing.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I think,
I dunno why, I'm oddly
calm during an earthquake.
And I remember like-
- I like it. You see
what I mean? It's good.
Woo!
- I wouldn't say I like it, right?
But it's like, I remember like,
'cause I remember seeing
Arkie's video of, that she took,
and I related to Joey.
So, of course, of course,
me and Joey sharing the same brain cell.
But I remember relating to
Joey so hard just seeing Arkie
just like freaking out,
going to the bed and Joey just sitting
with a stone-cold face on the couch,
which is just like experiencing
the world ending around him.
And Joey's just, this is fine.
It was literally just the "this is fine"
face look, you know?
- [Arkie] Joey?
(building rattling)
(object thudding)
(mechanical pulsing)
(Arkie sighing)
- [Joey] There was two earthquakes.
- [Arkie] Was it a level six just hit?
- Yeah, that was a level six.
- [Arkie] Fukushima.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- The one that got meme'd a lot online
was like afterwards, it started
to like really shake, right?
- Yeah.
- And so Arkie ran to the
other side of the house,
like to the bed because like
we always go to the bedroom
because there's nothing in our
bedroom other than our bed.
- Yeah.
- So, there's like,
we don't have any worry about
things like falling on us
and stuff like that.
- Yeah.
- So, we go to the bed,
she's like calling out to me.
I'm like, why the fuck
you calling out to me?
You're the one that left me behind.
(Garnt laughing)
- She like bolts, bolts into the bed.
She's like, "Joey, where are you?"
And I'm like, "What do you mean?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
You left me in the living room."
And so there's just this footage of me
just like casually
strolling in with my hand
on my hip being like,
"Oh, two earthquakes."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Oh, fucking sick.
- Yeah, and people are like,
just Joey, just like as a chat,
just like walking in, like dad pose.
Like hand on his hip.
Just like, I think someone said like,
"Why does he look like a dad
that's like waiting for
like an argument to finish?"
(all laughing)
It's just like.
But to be fair in my
defense, I was surprised
'cause I looked way calmer in that video
than I actually was.
'Cause I think in those
kinds of situations, like-
- Which earthquake was this?
- The one that happened yesterday.
- Oh, you had a video?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Arkie filmed it. Yeah.
Yeah, Arkie filmed it.
And, yeah, I think I was surprised
'cause I was like, oh, I looked way calmer
than I actually was.
'Cause inside I was like, oh fuck.
This is like really long.
Also I was worried about my grandma
'cause she lives up north.
- Right.
- So, I was like trying
to text her and stuff.
But outta context,
it just looks like me just
fucking standing there,
just like waiting for
this earthquake to end
like, come on.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- End already.
- End already, fark.
- I really want to go
on one of those like,
I know they had it in
like "Takeshi's Castle."
They had the challenge
where you had to like sit
in like the Japanese tatami room.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's on one
of those earthquake simulation things.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And they have to like try
and sit on the platform without
falling over while it's like magnitude 9.
- Oh yeah.
- I really wanna go in one of those.
- I've been on one of those.
- Oh, dude.
- Yeah.
- That sounds fun.
That sounds fun.
- Yeah, Arkie did a video
at like the like emergency
center type of thing in Japan.
And like where you get to
experience like a house fire
and like an earthquake
and stuff like that.
And they have one of those things.
And I tried it on magnitude 9,
which is the same as the 2011 earthquake.
Dude, it's crazy. Like-
- Right, what does it feel like?
- It just feels like four guys
are just surrounding
you and just doing this.
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
Like you can't even,
like I was sitting down like legs crossed,
I was sitting down.
And like after the first shake,
like I was like lying flat.
- [Connor] Holy shit.
- Right.
- You cannot even like lie down straight.
Like it's so fucking intense.
And so it really like
went to (indistinct).
Like, you know, when you
hear magnitude 9, right?
You're like, oh fuck,
that seems really big.
But I think like actually
experiencing magnitude 9
is another lever.
- Isn't it exponential?
- Yeah, I think they just like
whoever designed the Richter scale
really like fucked up by
making it a logarithmic scale.
'Cause it's not like
it's not linear, right?
So it's like by-
- It's logarith-
Do you mean exponential?
- I think that's the same thing.
- Well, I think
logarithmic is exponential.
- It's the inverse of exponential.
- Is it?
- So, logarithmic means
that it goes like this
and then exponential
means it goes like this.
- [Garnt] Okay. I might be wrong.
It might be-
- It's just-
- I just wanted to say logarithmic.
- One of them's like this, Garnt.
- Make myself sound smart.
- Garnt, logarithmic, exponential.
- I'm gonna Google this
right now. Which one is it?
- Logarithmic means that
it peak like the gains
that you see are initial and
then it starts flattening out.
Where as exponential's the opposite.
(Ashley speaking)
Oh, it is logarithmic?
- Thank you. Okay.
- But you were trying
to explain exponential.
- I smart. I smart.
- You said the right word,
but you were saying the wrong thing.
- No. What I'm saying is it-
- We're professionals.
- Like exponential is kind
of also logarithmic kind of.
- It's the inverse of logarithmic.
- Is it? I don't know
about that. I don't know.
I don't know because like-
- It's the opposite.
- I don't know, man. (chuckles)
- Either way it's-
- Okay.
- It's not linear.
- It's not linear. It's in a scale.
Yes. Yes, Ashley?
- [Ashley] Logarithmic functions
are the inverses of exponential functions.
- So, how is-
- So, Richter scale is logarithmic?
- [Ashley] Richter scale is logarithmic.
- So, that means that it would,
after like four or five,
the difference isn't much.
- That can't be right?
- No, no, no, no, no.
- [Ashley] It goes up this way.
Exponential goes up this way.
- No.
- [Garnt] No, no, no.
- No, it doesn't.
Hence the word exponential.
It goes exponentially higher.
- This kind of just-
- What!
- This kind of just proves my point.
(Connor laughing)
No, no, no, no, no.
- A bunch of wrong things.
I think I'm right.
- No, no, no.
The original point I was trying to make
was that they put it in a scale
that is not comprehendible
by the normal human person,
which we are literally proving right now.
You know, like, you hear like an 8 or 9
on the Richter scale and you're just like,
oh, that's just one up from a 7.
And I've seen people survive 7s.
- Right, right, right.
- Like your mind can't
comprehend the effects,
like the the tangible effects
of just how much larger that is, you know?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And that's why I think they fucked up.
Because if you hear like, oh,
it was on a scale of like a thousand
on like this earthquake scale.
You're like, that's a big number compared
to a hundred, which is what
we're technically talking about
when we're talking,
going up from magnitude 7
to a magnitude 8, right?
- Yes, yes.
And I think like,
I dunno why we went
with a logarithmic scale
for like disasters when the
normal person can't comprehend
that amount of difference with
just one number, you know?
- True, true.
- Yeah, I mean, Garnt
can't even comprehend
what logarithmic and an exponential are,
so how's he gonna comprehend the scale?
- I don't think any one of us can.
- I can, I know what it
is. I've just explained.
- [Ashley] Yeah, you're right.
- Yeah. (laughing) I know I'm right.
This is insane.
- But the Richter scale
is a logarithmic scale?
- Is that logarithmic?
Yeah, so that means that there
wouldn't be much difference
between 8 and 9.
- But there is.
- Well, the scale says
that there isn't, Joey.
- [Joey] Oh, fuck sake.
- Is that right?
There's not much of a
difference between 8 and 9?
- [Ashley] Logarithmic.
(Garnt laughing)
- But how we experience those numbers
are all different though.
So, it's like-
- I can't wait for the comments
to just tear this conversation apart.
- Hi, mathematician here.
(Garnt laughing)
I literally had an aneurysm.
- I invented the Richter scale.
- I'm having an aneurysm.
- [Ashley] Technically,
it's supposed to indicate
an intensity 10 times the previous number.
- Yeah, that's what-
- [Ashley] But it's also
described as a logarithmic scale.
So, I don't know.
They both seem-
- What does that mean?
- I thought like-
- Let me show you a picture
of a logarithmic fucking line.
- I know what a logarithmic line is,
but it doesn't make sense
because I've learned
that the Richter scale
is the higher the number,
the bigger the difference in scale.
- [Ashley] 10 times the difference.
- Yeah.
- I thought it was
like 10 times the previous number.
- Yeah. Right?
- No, 'cause what, I
mean, I guess it could be,
but also 'cause it goes like this, right?
- Right.
- So, let's say this was like, if it was 8
like at the peak or something.
It's not gonna get much better at 9.
So, increased more so.
- Well, then what? Oh
my God. I don't know.
- So, that's-
I am confusion. (laughing)
- But also a logarithmic
scale also depends
on the function you put into it.
- Yeah. That's what I thought.
'Cause the logarithmic
scale doesn't necessarily
have to look like that.
It's just a scale-
- It's a scale that's not linear.
- Yes.
It's not just a non-linear scale.
It's,
yeah.
So, that is a logarithmic-
- That is a logarithmic.
- And that is also what I understand
to be exponential as well.
That's what I thought.
- It's an exponential logarithmic scale.
- That's what I thought at least.
- It's an exponential logarithmic.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Oh, 'cause it keeps going up. Okay.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So-
- Either way-
- Either way, my original
point wasn't the fact
that exponentials are
the same as logarithmic.
That wasn't what I was trying to explain.
I was trying to explain that this shit-
- So, either way, I'm right. (laughs)
- Either way, I was trying to explain
that this shit is too confusing
for the normal person to comprehend.
- Yeah.
- Which maybe
we aren't normal.
We aren't the normal person.
Maybe we're just dumber
than a normal person.
- Speak for yourself.
- Maybe we're just dumber
than a normal person.
- Bottom line, you could say
that the earthquake yesterday
was magnitude 7.
- Yeah.
- But if you've never
been in an earthquake
of that magnitude, you're
not going to fucking know
what that feels like, right?
- Yeah.
- Like you guys have never
been in a magnitude 7.
Yesterday was a magnitude
like 4 max in Tokyo.
- Yeah. And like that's fun zone for me.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I think 6 sounds scary.
- 6.
I wonder how big the one in
LA was that we experienced?
- I wanna say that was
probably around the same.
Like maybe like a magnitude 4.
- It wasn't that bad.
- It felt around the same.
- Well, it depends
like where we were wasn't
it didn't feel that bad.
But I can't imagine what it
is Like even if it goes like,
if it's like 10 times
more powerful than that.
- I mean I've been in a 6,
is the biggest one I've been.
- Do you know, America has the
most volcanoes in the world?
- Does it?
- Not active, but total volcanoes.
- Oh really?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Whereabouts? Just Hawaii?
- The whole thing.
Well, I think Hawaii has
a lot of active ones.
- Right.
- But in general, America's a lot-
- More than Japan?
- Yeah. More volcanoes than Japan.
- Wow. I thought Japan had the most.
- No.
- Maybe Japan has the most active ones?
- No, that's Indonesia.
- Yeah. I think that is Indonesia.
- Japan can't be number
one for everything.
- Well, America also has
like a massive land mass.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So, I'm not like surprised about that.
- America has the most volcanoes
that like aren't active,
like they like don't do anything.
- Yeah.
- [Ashley] Yellowstone
- Yeah, then they have like Yellowstone,
which is like a ticking time
bomb for extinction, you know?
(Joey laughing)
I mean, it kind of is, right?
If Yellowstone ever explodes,
then humanity fucks.
- Yeah. Well, same with Mount Fuji, right?
- Yeah, I think as well,
is if any volcanoes erupt
in the Antarctic, I think,
there's some volcanoes underneath the ice.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And if they explode-
- Then Antarctica's just gone.
- Yeah.
- Well, that would be the world's gone.
That water's gotta go somewhere, Joey.
(all laughing)
- It doesn't just like go out into space?
- No, it doesn't unfortunately.
- [Joey] Turns into rain?
- Gravity's really good
at keeping that shit in.
- Yeah, which like, 'cause
yesterday made me wonder,
like it made me appreciate
just how prepared are you
for a disaster, right? Because-
- [Connor] Visos music.
- Huh?
- Visos music.
Right, because we're in the
penultimate episode of Earth,
I think right now.
- You think?
- This is like penultimate
episode kind of vibes.
- Wait, well, hold on. Wait.
- We got a war going on.
We got global warming with the pandemic,
the Earth's shaking,
trying to rip itself apart.
- Right.
- We're in the-
- The Mayans were off by a few years.
You know, when you have like
when it's like the disaster movie
and you have the beginning,
the act one, where you
have all of the indicators
that the world is ending, but
nobody pays attention to it.
I believe like 2020
has like literally been
that indicator IRL.
- Quick take a shot of the
seismograph, going crazy.
Get that on film.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, 'cause like I remember
like when the lights went out
and I was walking
around, I was like, okay,
if this was like-
- That's the title of the movie,
"When the Lights Went Out."
- "When the Lights Went out."
When we lost power, I was just like,
it made me think, what if
this was like actually just,
you know, a super,
super serious earthquake
and like the power would be out for a time
when I didn't know when
they would be back on.
- Well, you'd be fine
'cause you have a Gigan
shaft fucking battery.
(Connor singing)
- Which is just like, I kinda realized
how much foreshadowing of,
I'm gonna call it foreshadowing, right?
Because it's basically a
Chekhov's gun at this point,
of items I've collected
thanks to Trash Taste,
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
that would help me
through a disaster, right?
So, the first thing I realized is
our house was the only house on our street
with any lights on.
And that's because I had my
fucking brick of a power bank
that I had accidentally bought
for the camping episode.
Which if you need a flashback,
here's a thumbnail of the clip
of me talking about the brick
that I bought by accident
for the camping episode.
- Yeah. But it wasn't by accident.
- But it wasn't, I didn't
know, it wasn't by accident,
like the script-
- He foresaw what was gonna happen.
- The script writers for Trash Tastes
is just like on another level,
Like they foreshadowed
this like two seasons ago.
- (indistinct) is writing Garnt's life.
- So, like I remember the lights
being off and me thinking,
fuck, I do not have any torches
or any sources of power.
Wait a minute.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
And I remember,
I thought I'd never ever
actually be able to use it
for the use that it was intended for.
And luckily I had just
charged it like a week before.
So, like we just plugged,
we could literally just plug in our lamps
and we just lit up like our
bedroom, like it was normal.
- Plug in your entire house.
- Yeah, yeah.
We could charge our phones and everything.
But like beyond that, I was
also thinking, what if like,
what if this was a natural apocalypse
and we needed to survive
for, you know, a bit longer.
And I remember, do we have
like a good supply of water
or like supplies, emergency rations
to get us through the day?
And I was like, wait a minute.
I just bought an entire,
like me and Sydney both
have an entire fridge full
of green tea that we bought
as like an aesthetic thing
for our streams, right?
So, if you've seen any of my streams
or any of my on-camera shots,
there's a mini fridge that I have.
And that's just full of
green tea that could last me
for a decent amount of time.
And beyond that, I also have a backup,
just like an entire
crate full of green tea.
So, I can like constantly refill this up.
So, unknowingly, just from
trying to make something
look aesthetic in my background,
I'm able to like just survive-
- You'll be pissing so much though.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I'm able to survive. And not
only that, I'm just like,
do we have any food to
be able to like last us?
I'm like, Sydney's got like
10 months worth of Bokksu's
just lying about.
So, thanks to Bokksu,
we also have emergency rations as well.
- Wow.
- I've got like an emergency kit.
- Yeah. So, do I.
- Got like quite a lot of water.
- Mm.
- You got quite a lot of water?
- I've got like that bottle of water
that lasts like four
years or whatever it is.
- What?
- Yeah. There's like
emergency water that Japan
makes where it's like
water that supposedly
lasts like four or five years.
- Emergency water?
- What do you mean,
it would last four or five years?
- It's like been specifically made
so that it doesn't go off.
- Water can go off?
- Yeah, water can go off.
- What? I'm still gonna drink that shit.
(Ashley speaking)
- Yeah, water can get stagnant
and collect bacteria and stuff,
but like they have like special,
like it's like akusui,
it's called in Japanese.
- Oh, I've got like, I don't know,
like 10 liters of water or something.
- Can bottled water go off?
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- After a while, like after
like a year or something.
- I mean, you could still drink it.
- You can still drink it, but-
- You'll be fine. You'll be fine.
I've got like a bunch of food.
I got a wind up torch.
Got some other shit.
- Wait, so you actually
have an emergency kit?
- Yeah.
- Where did you buy it?
- They sell them on Amazon.
- Yeah.
- I just bought one.
- Arkie made one for a video.
- I thought if I don't use
it, I'll just whatever.
You know, I looked into, I
was like, oh, should I get one
of those solar panel
battery charging things?
Turns out they're like a lot of bullshit.
And they like barely work.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- So, I was like, oh,
and then someone's like,
just get wind up torch.
It's like way better.
I gotta wind up torch.
- Just get the fucking brick
shit-house battery pack,
like Garnt did.
- Yeah. But like you gotta
keep that thing fully charged.
If it's in my cupboard for like 12 months,
it might have half the charge
by the time I go to it.
- Yeah. Half the charge
could probably still last you
like six months. (chuckles)
- Yeah, I'm actually probably gonna get
like an emergency pack now.
'Cause I never really thought
about it before yesterday.
It did humble me a bit.
Just, you know, even though just-
- Even though you're
fully prepared. (laughs)
- Even though I am prepared in many ways.
Thanks to Trash Taste
and Trash Taste law and just
being a content creator.
You know, (laughs) I didn't
purposely prepare for it, but-
- Sorry, go on.
- But, yeah, I mean, I just
have a lot of things lying
in my house that is useful for survival.
- Do you ever watch those videos
that are like what to
do if there's a nuke?
- Oh, yeah.
- You're like, all
right. (heavy breathing)
- Yeah.
You mean like the lie
down with your mouth open
kind of thing?
Do you know that one?
- What's that one?
Hold on, tell me this.
- Apparently I saw a video.
I don't know how true it is,
but apparently it's like what
to do if a nuke explodes,
like not close enough
where it can like immediately kill you,
but its like if like the shock wave
could like possibly kill you.
And apparently, I don't
know if this is true,
so please take this with a grain of salt.
- Yeah.
- But it's like,
you have to supposedly lie
down with your like head
facing away from the blast
and you have to have your mouth open
because if your mouth is closed,
then the shock wave can
puncture your lungs.
- What?
- But if the mouth is open,
then it lets the air
escape from your mouth.
Supposedly, that's like
a trick that people
have just figured out.
Again-
- Mouth breathers rejoice.
- We were talking about-
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
We were talking about
useless skills, all right?
I know that little useless skill.
- That is-
- Or it could come very useful, who knows?
- That is a piece of knowledge
you see in one life
hack on a YouTube show.
And then you immediately forget about it.
(Connor singing)
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Actually, I wouldn't forget
that. That's very memorable.
- Yeah. I remember, and again,
I dunno how true this is.
I've never personally
experienced anything like that.
So, I haven't tested it myself.
- So, if I see a nuke going
off, I lie down on the ground.
- Yeah, so say if it's
coming out from that window
over there, you would face that way.
- How the fuck would you?
Calculations. Oh shit. (chuckles)
- Yeah. And yeah, you'd like
kind of have your head down
and you'd like open your
mouth so that the shockwave
can go through your body
rather than, 'cause if it's closed,
then it gets closed off and then-
- It's still gonna hurt a lot, right?
- Oh, it's still gonna hurt.
But it won't kill you is the thing.
- Oh God.
- I feel like if a nuke's going off,
your life's pretty fucked anyway, right?
- Well, I mean if your close
enough, yeah. (Garnt laughing)
Obviously.
- I think you have like-
- I don't think anyone who
was like, oh here's the nuke-
- Hold on, hold on, guys.
- Guys, I got it, I got it.
- Guys, open your mouths, guys.
(all laughing)
Trust me.
- Like the next Indiana
Jones he does like,
he fucks the fridge and
he just turns around
and with his mouth open. (laughs)
- No, he's like in the fridge
and he's like, "Oh fuck."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I forgot.
- That only works,
the only reason the fridge
technically worked, right?
Is 'cause it's a lead fridge, right?
They don't make lead fridges anymore.
- No, they don't.
- So, I can imagine a
bunch of people jumping
in their fridges and it's like,
it's not gonna do anything.
You just put yourself in a coffin.
- Yeah. Basically.
- You just made it-
- You're just gonna cook
yourself alive, yeah.
- So, it was like they were saying
'cause you have 15 minutes
when the nuke goes off,
if you're not in the
immediate danger zone.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You're 15 minutes
before like the fallout
reaches the ground level.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Mm.
- So, you need to get
indoors within 15 minutes
and not leave,
but you still might be
dead from the radiation.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, of course.
- But obviously if you
get any fallout on you,
I think you die.
- Yeah. Probably.
- Radiation sickness sounds horrible.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Really, really, dude, Chernobyl, man,
that HBO series was like rough.
- Well, it wasn't just that.
I think the one thing that
really horrified me was hearing
about that Japanese guy who was like,
I think he was like the
most radioactive person
who ever lived.
- Oh. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think I remember seeing this.
- I saw a documentary on it or-
- Was it the one on the fisherman?
Is this that one?
- I don't think it was a fisherman.
- [Connor] Oh, okay.
- He was working for, I believe,
a nuclear power plant
or something like that.
So, for what, I don't know the full story,
but for whatever reason, during routine
maintenance thing, with
when he was handling
radioactive material, they made a mistake
due to like time constraints
and, you know, trying
to get this project done
faster than usual.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- So, they were pouring
way more radiation material
into this tank than was ever
allowed by regulations, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And, you know, obviously
a chain reaction happened,
something went wrong.
And this guy who was literally standing
right next to the tank,
right next to the tank
pouring in this radioactive material,
he got hit by the full blast of this chem-
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- This chemical reaction
that was happening, right?
So, he was literally the
most radioactive person
who has ever been documented
in history, right?
- Damn.
- And it's like
a fucking horrific story of like,
he actually survived it initially, right?
He survived it initially
and they went to hospital.
And he, on the first day,
he looked so well that
the nurses were like ready
to discharge him the next day.
- Mm.
That is until they like
looked at his like DNA
and his DNA had been obliterated like-
- Jesus.
- Like fucking obliterated.
Right?
And I don't think like
anyone at that point realized
the gravity, aside from
like the doctors, of course,
realized the gravity of
just like what was in store
for this guy.
Because like he got to the point where,
because his cells could
not make new cells, right?
So, he got to the point
where the doctors were trying
to save him because his family
and himself wanted, you know,
to try everything they could.
But I feel like it
would've been less painful
just to let him pass away.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because like,
he got to this point where his body
just started deteriorating,
his skin would fall off
and would start bleeding and pussing
and he like, they could do
nothing, but just bandage him up.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- Because there was no way
for like for his body to make new cells.
And he basically just
deteriorated to death
and it's like-
- Geez.
- You hear about the accounts
of this and it sounds like fucking-
- That's probably the
worst way, worst way.
- That was like one of
the worst ways to die.
- I was thinking of a different story
of like the guy who was
like living in Hiroshima
during World War II.
And then when the bomb dropped, right?
And he survived that one.
- Yeah, I know this one.
- And he escaped with his family
out of Hiroshima to Nagasaki
- Oh.
- [Garnt] Oh.
(Garnt laughing)
- And then the second bomb dropped.
And he survived that one as well.
- [Connor] Mm.
- I thought
you were talking about that story.
- Oh no, no, no.
- [Connor] I think-
- He must have been pretty
radioactive after that.
- Apparently, I dunno if this is true,
but I remember hearing that there's more,
it was not just him. There's
a few other people as well,
but they reckoned that maybe a hundred
or so people had the same experience.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But they just dunno who they are.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But I mean, that is crazy.
Really crazy.
- Yeah, yeah. Definitely.
Just like thinking about this.
- Shivers.
- So, there's a YouTuber,
I can't remember his name,
he talks about a lot of
these radiation stories
and mistakes and stuff.
I can't remember his name.
He does the science videos as well.
Fuck, I can't remember his name.
They're really, really good.
- [Joey] Right.
- And there's some other horrible
stories about like people
doing experiments that went wrong.
- There was that other
story, I think I know
which YouTuber you're talking about.
Did he make a-
- The guy with the amazing hair?
- Yeah.
Did he make that video on the
guy who like stuck his head
in the Hadron Collider?
- Yeah. So, yeah, it was-
- And he got like shot by plasma-
- It wasn't the Hadron Collider,
but it was I think a similarish thing.
Yeah, he got shot by an atom-
- Yeah.
- In the head.
- And it like penetrated his
brain and he survived it.
But like, but yeah.
And then there was some like mix up
where they thought he was alive.
- He has like amazing hair.
He's got like a lions mane.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
This guy's amazing.
- Not the guy who got shot.
The guy who makes the YouTube videos.
- Oh, okay 'cause I was about
to say like is this some-
- Kyle Hill.
- Is this some new kind of like therapy
to give you like
amazing hair? Just get shot by an atom.
(Joey laughing)
Shot by an atom. (laughing)
- Are you experiencing hair loss? Boom!
- You've definitely seen this thumbnail.
It's called The Demon Core.
Have you seen this one?
- Oh yeah, yeah. I've seen that.
- That was a good video.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- That was a horrible
story though as well.
People fucking around with this thing
and then it goes wrong and then like all
the scientists die.
- [Garnt] What's a demon core?
- It was just like nuclear active core.
- It's always nuclear. (laughs)
- And it was, I can't
remember exactly what it was.
Watch the video, it's really good.
And it was just telling about the story.
And it's really, really strange.
Sometimes you just think like, why?
Just leave it. Just don't.
- What happened with the
guy who got shot by an atom?
- I think he survived.
- He survived but then he unsurprisingly
developed these like really
weird like brain traumas.
And like he, I think he had like-
- [Connor] He survived.
He definitely survived.
- He survived for a while I believe.
But like he lost a lot of
his hair and then he, yeah,
he just had all these like
weird brain complications
that the doctors were like,
I dunno what the fuck to do with this.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- He's currently
79-years-old and living.
- 79 Years old and living? Okay.
What a fucking badass
title, got shot by an atom.
- So, we know that 100%
of the time, as we know,
when you put a head in an-
- A Hadron Collider.
- You survive.
We have a hundred percent survival rate.
We know that, we know.
(all laughing)
- Oh, I'll fucking stick my head
in there like tomorrow, right?
- Jump in the Hadron Collider real quick.
- There's been other cases as well,
people will get the, what's
the thing that powers x-rays?
I think there's like, is it something?
There was one guy, I dunno
if it was an x-ray exactly.
But it was a medical device.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And some people
broke into an abandoned hospital
and like stole this thing.
- [Garnt] Right.
- And they just thought
it was some kind of
like cool glowing thing.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Turns out that cool glowing thing
was like radioactive like
uranium or something.
And yeah, I can even be mixing
up two stories together here.
It was on his channel
as well, really weird.
- And now they're the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
- I think like the whole,
it might be a different story actually,
but like the whole
village, they were like,
everyone come check
out the glowing stones.
- Oh no.
- No joke.
And people were all touching
it and playing with it.
And like a whole like family
and a few other people died
'cause they were just touching
and playing with the stone.
- Fucking hell.
(Joey muttering)
- Don't ever touch glowing stones, kids.
- If it's glowing,
that's probably a bad sign
that a chemical reaction
is happening there that you
shouldn't be holding, right?
- Curse glow sticks, curse
glow sticks for making us think
that things that glow are so cool.
God damn it.
This video is sponsored by Bokksu.
Bokksu here is a monthly
snack box subscription service
that delivers premium Japanese
snacks and tea pairings
straight from Japan to your door.
Every single be-(lips
smacking)-autiful Bokksu here
has their very own gourmet theme
that changes every single month.
The first Bokksu that you will receive
is called the Seasons of Japan,
curated by their snack
experts to bring you a taste
of Japan's four seasons
and taste what a year
of Bokksu would be like.
Following the Seasons of
Japan, you'll receive a new,
beautiful snack box, just like this one,
themed every single month.
And this theme is tanjobi,
which, if you don't know, in
Japanese just means birthday.
And there is snacks in
this book from every single
part of Japan.
I've had these before,
which are delicious,
and a bunch of these I've had before.
But some of these I've never seen before.
And of course, there's
a tea pairing with it.
So, if you want to try some of
the authentic Japanese snacks
in here and support me and the boys,
you can do so right now,
just smash that link in
the description down below.
And when you're there,
use coupon code
TRASHTASTE15 to get $15 off
your first Bokksu order.
- Do you guys reckon you could survive
the zombie apocalypse?
- No.
(Garnt laughing)
- Although maybe.
- Bro, they got Uber Eats still going?
If not, no, I'm done, I'm out.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
What's the point? What's the point, dude?
- It is, but he's also a zombie.
- Yes.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Like, eh.
- Like, do you want to
survive a zombie apocalypse?
- I don't know. I don't know.
- It depends where you are, right?
Like if you're in an
area that's just like,
you're the only one remaining,
like there's just zombies fucking clawing
at your apartment or whatever.
Then it's just like, just take me.
- At that point, I'm just like, okay,
well, the world's fucked anyway.
- Yeah.
- You know, whatever.
- Well, I mean, (sighs) I don't know.
I feel like a zombie apocalypse
wouldn't be that hard to survive.
- That's what I'm like.
That's my biggest like,
unless it depends on the
type of zombie, right?
'Cause if you're talking
about like the traditional,
really slow fucking
zombie, that fucking walks
like one mile an hour, I'm just like,
how did this become an
apocalypse in the first place?
How are people this incompetent
that this became an actual apocalypse?
- In all those movies,
they're just like, "No, don't come near."
While they standing still, right?
It's like, "No." (moaning)
- If it's "28 Days Later," all right,
now I get how it could become a-
- If we're like talking like
CoD zombies, then it's like,
yeah, I'm fucked.
- But I feel like, you know
how like some of the movies
they make, they manage
to make like villages
that are like really
tall walls and no one can
get in and stuff.
I feel like that would be-
- If I've learned
anything from Dead Rising,
it's just stay at a mall.
- Yeah, yeah.
Hit them with a foam bed.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Combined with a chainsaw.
- Hit 'em with a bench.
- Put the machine guns on the wheelchair.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then drive the wheelchair.
- And I feel like, you know,
I feel like if a zombie
apocalypse ever did happen,
that's the one place where,
you know, being in America
would be a massive fucking advantage.
'Cause you think about how
easy it is to gain access
to weapons here in Japan.
- Until the zombies learn about those
and they're like, "We can
use this too." (growls)
- Oh, I thought you were gonna be like,
'cause you can just go like North Dakota
and there's no one there.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Or that, true.
- Escape to Wyoming.
- Oh, you're in Idaho?
Zombies actually don't want to go there.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(all laughing)
They like go to the board, and like, err.
- Oh, mm.
- Err.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, I mean, that's the one place
where if you have a gun,
it'll be like very, very useful.
- But you're assuming
guns will stop zombies.
- Exactly.
- That is true. That is true.
- Because like games
have led us to believe
that it's like, do you
want to kill a zombie?
Just get good at head shots.
But it's like-
- [Connor] Fuck, yeah.
- Realistically, will it
actually kill a zombie?
- How much ammo can you
really get a hold of?
You know, Resident Evil
got one thing right.
It'd be fucking annoying
to be like conserving
your ammo with this shit.
(Garnt laughing)
- Actually like I would be that guy.
I would be that guy, where you have-
- "Oh my God, shoot it!"
Garnt's like, "No, I'm sorry,
man, I got four bullet left."
(all laughing)
- I wouldn't be like, a zombie
could be right in front of me
and I'd be like searching
for like an ax or something.
Be like, I don't need to shoot a zombie.
I don't need to shoot a zombie.
You know, maybe I'll need this ammo
for like the boss
battle, whatever that is.
- Katana collection boys are
winning, that's for sure.
- I would do anything I could,
even if I had a gun, to not use a gun
just in case, just in case.
- I gotta go back to the safe
room to like buy more bullets.
- In a zombie apocalypse,
probably honestly the best thing
you could probably have is
just having a medieval set
of armor and weapons.
- Yeah. Like a sword.
- How the fuck they gonna bite you?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- If you're wearing
a full like chain mail and
you've got a big-ass long sword.
- [Joey] That's true.
- I think you're good.
I think you're good.
Those chats on YouTube,
the ones you're talking about,
the correct sword techniques.
They're gonna be the real winners.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause that's what
I've always like struggled
to figure out, right?
Like the video game logic of, yeah,
just shoot 'em in the
head and it'll stop them.
And I'm like, but they're dead already.
(Garnt laughing)
Why would they die like
a normal human being?
- I mean, I don't know it.
Yeah. It depends how the zombies function.
If it's a parasite taking over the body.
- Yeah, we're talking about fake, I mean,
fake science now.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
You know, could be any sort
of reason or any sort way
to kill a zombie.
- If you just like, you know,
if you have a fucking Katana
or something and you just like, you know,
chop their body into bits,
then they can't do anything, right?
Even if they're still alive.
- You gonna chop someone's
body into bits, Joey?
You know how long that's gonna take?
- How long is it gonna
take one zombie, Joey?
- [Connor] You're gonna be knackered.
- It's the zombie apocalypse, Joe.
- I'll take 'em out one
at a time, you know?
- Joey's gonna like sit
down and have a breather
when he's done like-
- Like hold on, guys.
- Joey thinks a katana
works like it does in anime
where he just like does
like the fucking sword thing
and like the zombie's in a hundred pieces.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- That's true.
Alight. You know what?
Guns guns are good.
- Probably a flamethrower's
pretty good, right?
- Flamethrower, yeah.
- Is a flamethrower an actual good weapon
or is it just like an aesthetic weapon?
- It's a very good weapon.
It's a waste of money.
But I mean, if you hit someone
with it, they die, Garnt.
- But what-
- I know that, but I should-
- Yeah but wouldn't the
fuel for a flamethrower tank
be more scarce than bullets?
- Yeah.
Surely there's more
effective weapons and like,
it looks cool and it's effective,
but surely there's more efficient weapons,
I should say than the-
- Chainsaw.
- It's like wildly inefficient.
But like if you hit
someone I think with it,
I think they just, 'cause
like the ones that like,
I think like Elon Musk sells, for example.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's basically
just like a hair spray with a lighter.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
But I think the original
ones in like World War II
were like, they would actually
shoot out oil on fire.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause you could see
the streams of liquid.
So, they would land and hit.
And obviously if you get hit with that,
that's just gonna like burn through.
- Well, of course,
but like what I'm trying
to say is you, you know,
you have two guys,
one person has a flamethrower,
one person has a gun.
I think the person with
a gun is going to win
kinda outta that battle, right?
- Yeah. But you're not fighting,
you're fighting a zombie.
- That's true. That's true.
Okay. Okay, okay.
- I feel like your goal
is to make it so the zombie can't move.
What a weird topic.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I feel like your goal,
'cause you don't even know
if you can kill it?
What if the gun doesn't
work? What if it doesn't-
- But what if the zombie
doesn't feel the heat?
- But what if you burn off like his legs?
- But you could just chop
off his legs as well.
- Are you gonna chop off his legs?
(Garnt laughing)
- I dunno.
- Are you gonna be hacking away.
How long is that gonna take?
- Joey's just living like the anime dream
of like using his katana now.
- I just want to Kirito okay?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I admit it.
I just wanna come out
and just fucking do this.
(Garnt laughing)
- [Connor] If you just like-
- Just duel with the swords.
- If you just burned
off his arms and legs,
he wouldn't be able to move.
- I just wanna be Guts.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
What about like a chainsaw then?
- Yeah. That's pretty-
- I feel that'd be more-
- Gods of Wars has
probably got that right.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Also, but I wonder, no, no, no.
Yeah, I wonder if like
bones would like clog
a chainsaw or do anything?
Probably not 'cause I
think trees are stronger
than bones, I think.
- Are they?
- I don't know. I don't know actually.
- But we don't build
houses out of bones, Garnt.
(Joey laughing)
- Well that's because we don't
really farm bones, do we?
(all laughing)
We don't have a forest full
of bones that we can farm
and build houses out of.
- That sounds like an aesthetic,
build a house out of bones, dude.
That sounds fucking badass.
- [Garnt] It does. (laughing)
- That's like a Tim Burton movie waiting.
- That's what you can do,
right? In the zombie apocalypse.
You collect the limbs and
you just take the bones out
and just make a house out of it.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
There you go. Problem solved.
Recycling in the zombie apocalypse.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- The one thing that
zombies can't penetrate,
a house full of bones.
- Because they'd be like, "Oh,
you're just one of us
with a few extra bones."
(Garnt laughing)
I'm not gonna go near that.
- Yeah, I think in some countries as well
you're not allowed to fill
up a gas canister as well,
I think it's illegal.
So, you wouldn't be able
to get a stock pile of gas.
- 'Cause it turns into a weapon?
- Ah, normally it is when
the government is concerned
that your population
might be making weapons.
- Right, right.
- Oh, okay.
- Molotov cocktails. Things like that.
- That makes sense.
- Yeah.
- So-
- But will they care
during a zombie apocalypse?
Is the question. (sniggers)
- No. True.
- [Joey] They're not gonna be like-
- Step number one, you've
gotta get a container.
And number two, you're probably
not gonna be the first guy
at the gas station.
Let's be honest.
- [Joey] That's true,
that's true.
- We've seen it
when gas prices, when we hear about
gas shortages, everyone goes-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's already too late.
I guess that's the first
thing you should do
in any apocalypse, is
immediately go to the gas place
and get, I don't even have a
car, but I'm getting the gas.
- [Garnt] Yeah. I'm getting gas.
- 'Cause I know I'm gonna be
king when people want gas.
I'm like, well I can give you it.
I have four tanks in the back.
- [Joey] That's true.
- I'm like covered in
like fucking black smoot.
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah, 'cause I was thinking
because like I feel like
part of the reason why
it's so hard to get people
to take action over,
I dunno, like real life
apocalypses that could be happening
right now is because real life apocalypses
sound so fucking boring.
Like, oh, like, oh, the
temperature of the Earth's
slowly changing by a
few degrees every year.
And we need to do the best to Earth.
Like that sounds so boring
like compared to like,
we are being invaded by hoard of zombies
and only you can take them on with a-
- Global warming is the
least sexy apocalypse.
- [Garnt] Yeah, right?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Right.
- Let's be honest.
- The Chad versus like
a virgin apocalypse.
- Everyone likes the zombie thing
because they think that
they're gonna become the Chad
who games the system, becomes this king.
- Because it's all in video games, right?
Like when have you heard
of a fucking video game
where you have to fight global warming?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Maybe we need that.
- We need that.
- We need that in real life.
- I mean, let's be honest, right?
I think in a zombie apocalypse,
you're gonna die from another person.
Not a zombie.
- The people who made Dead Rising
just need to make like Heat Rising.
- [Connor] Right now.
- Something like that.
- You go to prison for 20
years if you kill someone,
(all laughing)
and people still do it.
In a zombie apocalypse, there's
not gonna be any punishment.
People are gonna start killing everyone.
- [Garnt] That's true. That's true.
- Everyone's gonna be like, "Oh my God.
that one guy pissed me off on the train.
I'm gonna go find him."
- Yeah.
I feel, yeah, I feel
during a zombie apocalypse,
everyone's just gonna be so on edge
that you're probably gonna
get killed by another human
before you get killed by a zombie.
- There's no way anyone
would admit to being bitten.
Like I thought everyone who
didn't admit to being bitten
in a zombie movie was the asshole.
But in reality, we've been
through a pandemic now.
That's just like most of the
human race at this point.
- Yeah.
- Like if you got-
- You also probably have to
kill other people as well.
- Yeah.
- Of course. Of course.
- If you wanna get their stuff.
- [Garnt] Of course.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I'm just saying.
- It's just a Battle Royale now.
- If Fortnite has taught me anything,
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
kill them.
- If that old grandma has a full supply
of water and food, I'm sorry.
- Zoom was already man.
Fortnite has trained
them just how to kill-
- Just border up the fucking
house in two minutes.
(all laughing)
- The zombie apocalypse happens
and you just hear (knocking)
with like, ssh.
(both singing)
- Dude, we're fucked,
we live in like Japan,
the last person you ever go against
in a video game is like
16-year-old Asian kids.
'Cause they're just insane.
Well, we'd be killed.
(Garnt laughing)
- Sure.
- They're like challenger rank.
And we're like trying to
figure out what's going on.
And they've already built a fortress.
- They've been perfectly
trained by Fortnite, Minecraft
to build the perfect fortress.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Unironically, these
kids would've somewhat
of an understanding of basic
survival 'cause of Minecraft.
- Yeah. More than us, right?
(all laughing)
- Exactly. You're actually right.
That's something to think about.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God.
- They know how to
craft all the materials.
- It's not good but it offers something.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It offers something.
- They at least know that coal
can be turned into charcoal.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's useful to know.
- 'Cause we're talking about
going back to useless skills,
like I think I feel like I should know
more survival skills than I do.
- No, no, you shouldn't, you shouldn't.
- Why? Why? I mean, I've seen you-
- God. You're like, please,
please, I need to survive.
- I've seen you try to start
a fire with a piece of flint.
And that didn't go well.
- That's why I feel like I need to learn
more survival skills than I already do.
- Would you ever get a bunker?
Like a bunker in your house?
- Like a bomb bunker?
- Yeah. Like a shelter.
- That'd be cool.
- But, yeah, if you're
like traveling a bunch
for your work, it's useless.
- Yeah. Yeah, it is.
But it's just cool, you know.
I wouldn't want a bunker for emergencies.
I would just want a bunker
because it's just cool
to have like a secret bunker.
- Have you seen that guy on
YouTube who's building one?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Colin Furze.
Like a whole bunker underneath his house.
- Underneath his garden.
There's actually one company in Japan
that can build bunkers.
- How much is a bunker?
- It's like, it depends on the size,
but it's like $50,000 or something.
- Can we build a bunker?
- If you have like-
- Trash Taste bunker.
- Trash Taste bunker. (laughing)
- Trash Taste emergency bunker.
- Garnt, we need land for that.
- It's true.
- We don't have land, Garnt.
(all laughing)
None of us own land.
- Buy the land first
and you can do whatever
the fuck you want with it.
- Yet, yet.
- That's what I'm gonna do.
If I ever buy land in the future here,
I'm like, fuck the house,
build a bunker first.
- Who needs a soundproof-
- Honestly, there's just
something about the idea
of building a bunker
that just like no matter
how old you are, it just fulfills
like this childhood dream.
- It's like a tree house.
- It's kind of like the next
level tree house, right?
- It's kinda like exciting.
It's like your kinda place.
- Yeah. It's like a secret base, right?
- Yeah, just imagine-
- Wait, what's the
difference between a basement
and a bunker?
- Huh?
- A basement is just like
an underground like...
I think a bunker is
supposed to be like secured.
- Yeah. It's supposed to be secured.
- With like concrete or-
- You can survive there, you know,
a basement is just a roof.
- There's tons of basements in London.
It's like three story basements.
- But they're not bunkers.
- But I thought like three levels deep,
which some of these basements are.
- Well, when I think of a bunker-
- If you're three level deep.
That's probably good, right?
- Maybe you can convert
that into a bunker.
But when I think bunker,
I don't just think a room,
you know, I think like a
sizeable amount of secret space
that's secure and you can be like-
- I think like the only way
to get in is through a hatch.
(Garnt laughing)
You know, like that's what
I think when I think bunker.
- Yeah, right, right.
- Not like a welcome to
the bunker. (all laughing)
- Open the plywood door.
(Joey imitating creaking door)
- That's not a bunker, you know.
- Move the ethnic looking beads
out of the way to get
into the room, the bunker.
- Place the book in the bookshelf.
- I really want a basement.
I just wanna have a basement.
- I wanna bunker.
- Then, no, you want a basement.
- Did you ever have like a tree house
or anything like that as a kid growing up?
- Who the fuck had a tree house?
- That's what I'm saying.
- [Connor] No one had a tree house.
- A tree house was this
mythical thing that some kids
talked about, but I'd
never known a single person
who had a tree house.
- My friend had a tree house.
- [Garnt] He had a tree house?
- Because there's always that one kid
who has that one dad who's
like never tired after work
and actually wants to do shit.
And he actually gets shit done.
- No, it was the one dad
that worked from home.
- Oh. Oh, okay.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was the one dad
that worked from home.
- Checks out, checks out.
- Also the construction dance.
- [Joey] Yep.
That was my task.
- Ah, they get shit done.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
My friend, but it wasn't like a massive
like fucking Simpsons
tree house looking thing.
It was literally like
enough to maybe fit like two
five-year-olds in.
Like an adult would not
be able to fit in that.
- Why a tree house?
I've always wondered, why?
- 'Cause it feels like a one with nature.
- Because it's just
kind of cool to be able
to like sit comfortably-
- [Connor] Those poor trees-
- On a tree.
- We mock it by taking its own kind
and fashioning it into a house
and putting it on top of it.
How cruel of us. How cruel.
- It's kinda like building
a house outta bones.
(all laughing)
- No, a dog house.
- A dog house made out of dog bones?
- [Connor] Yeah.
(all laughing)
- Fucking hell.
- It's actually kinda
true, that is. (laughing)
When you put it like that.
- It's kinda fucked up, yeah.
- Can we Google are there
any houses made out of bones?
(all laughing)
Can we fact check that?
Tim Burton must have a
house made out bones.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I refuse to believe-
- If anyone is gonna have
a house out of bones,
it's Tim Burton.
- I wanna build a bunker now.
I just wanna build a space.
- Right.
- I do want
a basement, let's just start
off with a basement, right?
- Did you, did you not have a basement?
- No, I've never had, no,
I've never had a basement.
Sorry? Sorry?
- Going back to another question.
I'm ignoring your basement.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Which one of us would
survive the longest
in a zombie or some kind of apocalypse,
do you think? And why?
- I don't know. It's a good question.
I feel-
- I feel Garnt would trust
someone and be betrayed by them.
- I feel you would just be like,
I'll be the alpha male and
just go out immediately
and just get killed.
(all laughing)
- That's so right.
That's so true.
- You're like, "Outta the way boys.
I got this. Aah."
- I feel like you would come
up with like the perfect plan
of how to survive the zombie apocalypse-
- And then not follow the plan. (laughing)
- And then you'd somehow
like overlook something
at step one.
(all laughing)
Out of confidence or something.
- I feel like Joey wouldn't
realize the apocalypse
is going on, except-
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- The moment I would realize-
- "Oh, sorry, mate. I was
playing PhotoFantasy."
(all laughing)
- The moment when I realize
is when you're dead.
(all laughing)
- Guys, I turned up to the (indistinct)-
- Like, where is everyone?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
It must be the wrong day.
- I was too busy meditating,
watching Pokemon.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I just escaped to my mind palace.
- Yeah, I don't know.
Like, I feel like we have
different varying degrees
of survival instincts,
but I don't feel any one
of our survival instincts
is particularly strong either. (laughs)
I mean, I guess, we're all like,
maybe we should do a survival special too.
- I feel the best way to determine
how someone would survive
in a zombie apocalypse is
how they play Dead Rising.
Because I think-
- Well, no it's not.
- Yeah, because it is.
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
- No, it is not.
You are talking outta your ass.
- No, because I feel like
people who are just like,
"I'm just gonna fucking pick up something
and charge right into the crowd."
Are the people who would not
survive a zombie apocalypse.
- Like pick up what? A newspaper?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Why would anyone go into a newspaper?
- Like, "I'm gonna pick up this
tennis ball, see much damage
it does to the zombies."
That's the kind of person who
would just be like, "Charge."
- I don't think anyone's doing that,
but I dunno like everyone,
I don't know what I'd do
in a zombie apocalypse.
I mean, everyone would be like-
- Cry.
- Yeah, just cry.
- Just cry.
- Just camp and like-
- Break down and cry. (lips blowing)
- I mean, you just try
to stay in the same place
for as long as possible.
- I think you'd have to find a
sidekick as soon as possible.
- A sidekick? (laughing)
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
What, like Robin?
- Listen, if you're gonna survive,
you need to become the main character,
how do you become the main character?
By getting a sidekick.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Right? You get a sidekick.
- What are you gonna run around
in like the fucking
apocalypse town and be like,
"Who wants to be my sidekick?"
(all laughing)
- [Connor] You know, you-
- If you'd like to survive, come with me.
- You're just walking around.
You're like, all right a
zombie is about to destroy,
about to kill this 10-year-old kid.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You save the kid.
You're like, "All right, fine.
I'll look after you."
Now, you're their main character.
- Yeah. But then you have to take care
of a fucking 10-year-old.
- Yeah, I mean, that
obviously is the downside,
but then if something happens-
- You can just chuck the
10-year-old. (chuckling)
- Okay. (laughing)
(all laughing)
Yeah.
- You're like, "Sidekick, do your job."
- "You're bait." Innit?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- 'Cause he's only 10 years old.
So, he doesn't need as
much food as a full adult.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
So, then you can make him go
and like lookout or something.
- Right, so just bait.
- You know.
I think like finding a
kid and then making him
like do all the tedious tasks
is probably a good idea.
- But what-
- It just sounds like
a parent at that point.
- Yeah.
- Well, yeah, but.
(all laughing)
But also you'd get some tangible benefit.
But whereas in real life you don't,
he just fucks off and
then goes to move to Japan
and doesn't contact you for months.
(Garnt laughing)
- Okay, okay.
Not a zombie apocalypse,
what if it was like
you're in "Lost" or something.
- Okay, okay.
- You're stranded on a desert island.
Who would survive the longest?
- On a desert island?
- Yeah. You're in "Lost."
You've seen "Lost," right?
- Probably me, because I'm
the most familiar with like-
- [Connor] Maybe.
- Wildlife and just like dangerous shit.
- You are?
I'm just-
- That's just the Ozzie advantage.
- Yeah, exactly.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I would definitely-
- All right, you kids, outta the way.
- I would definitely
eat something and die.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I would get food poisoning.
- Yeah, you would get food poisoning.
(all laughing)
- It's an illness. It's an illness.
- I'm not sick, lads.
I'm not sick.
I could still go out spear fishing.
(all laughing)
- The one time Connor
loves that food poisoning
and isn't honest.
(all laughing)
- It's a poisoning, Garnt,
hence why it's called food poisoning.
- Oh my God.
- You see the reason why I think
you would have an easier time surviving
the zombie apocalypse is because
you almost get a tangible
benefit from being an asshole,
being a piece of shit.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But in a desert's island,
you have to actually work together.
- Yeah.
Because if you're the asshole,
then you're the one that's
gonna be exiled, right?
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And you need as much
help as you can get.
- Joey's like a few steps ahead
where you have like a fucking society now.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- [Connor] Well, yeah, of course-
- It's like "Lord of the
Flies." Like. (laughs)
- I just don't wanna be exiled, man.
Well, I was thinking about
how to start a fucking fire
before I get exiled.
- To the other side of
the island with you!
- On a desert island, right?
'Cause you can't steal people's
food or whatever, right?
You have to work together.
- Yeah.
- In the zombie apocalypse
you could just go steal someone's house,
go and, you know, steal someone's house.
- That's true. That's true.
- Steal someone's house?
- Sorry. Go steal their
stuff from their house.
- Yeah. That's true.
- You know, but, yeah-
- You're very limited on an island, right?
- Yeah. You gotta work together.
- You can't really hide on an island.
- One of you fishes, one
of you doesn't make a fire.
(Joey laughing)
- And one makes a house full of bones.
- This conversation's making
me like wanna just learn
a lot more survival tips
and survival instincts
that I don't know now because-
- Just drink your own piss.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Have you done that?
I do it all the time, just
to get ready. (all laughing)
Just in case, you never know.
- Just put it through
a Brita filter, innit.
That will sort out the piss.
- I watched the survival man thing.
He was like, even if you're
on like a raft in the ocean.
You should never drink your own piss.
- Really?
- It's worse.
Apparently you should
never drink your own pee.
- Why?
- See, like-
- Apparently, even if
you're super dehydrated,
apparently it makes it worse.
- But that's so conflicting
because it's either everything
I've seen about drinking
your own piss is either,
never drink your piss or
always drink your piss.
(all laughing)
- It is true.
No, I agree, I agree.
- It's never in between.
(all laughing)
You know, it's weird.
I actually had the same
thought where I'm like,
this is so conflicting.
One minute, Bear Grylls is
absolutely like smashing
his own piss down like it's a beverage.
- I would recommend, 10 outta 10.
- And then there's another
time where it's like,
absolutely do not drink
your own piss ever.
- I just wasn't expecting. (laughing)
Oh, you think on like the scale
there should be like
a drink pissing scale.
(Joey laughing)
There should be a middle ground
on whether we should be
drinking piss or not.
- There's a lot of
misinformation about pee drinking
that I think needs to be corrected.
I would like to know.
- There's never a video that I have seen
where the guys like, you may
consider drinking your piss.
- I'm always like you think
under certain circumstances,
maybe you should be able to drink piss.
- I think it's about filtering it.
You need to find a way to filter it.
- Bear Grylls doesn't filter it, does he?
- I distinctly remember
there's one time where
he
pissed in a snake.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- While it was alive?
- Not while it was alive.
(all laughing)
Not while it was alive.
Can you get this?
(Ashley mumbling)
Well, yeah, I think it was a
dead snake that he'd killed.
I think, can you Google this?
And he turned it into like a water sack
by pissing in it.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- And I think, I don't know how,
I don't know how-
- This just sounds like a meme.
- [Connor] This does.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Can you check this out?
- It's like a parody
of a Bear Grylls video.
- [Ashley] Urinating into snake skin.
- Yeah, and I think it filters
it or something, somehow?
Or makes it somewhat
edible or I don't know.
- Was it Bear Grylls who like used condoms
as like a device to hold
water or I might just like-
- Probably, yeah.
- I dunno. Why?
- Yeah. I dunno why that-
- Why would we have condoms?
(all laughing)
- Oh, Bear Grylls who comes
to a desert islands with condoms.
Oh, have a seat, have a seat, Bear Grylls.
You brought Hard Mike's Lemonade
and condoms to the desert island, huh?
- Ah look, now what do we have
here? It's the condom tree.
(all laughing)
I dunno if I can just
pick a condom of this?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- This isn't a sign out a
happiness skit. I think-
- I dunno why I've heard that, yeah,
condoms are very useful for
holding bodies of water in case
you need to survive.
I don't know who said that to me
or if it's Bear Grylls or
not, but I'm just like-
- Wasn't that just like
a YouTube challenge?
- It's gonna be real annoying
getting that lube out
of that condom, man.
Why are we pissing in the snake again?
What was the purpose?
- To survive?
- [Ashley] He said to have
required the additional liquid
as a last resort for whatever reason.
- So, basically survival instincts,
which is what we're arguing here.
I'm not saying like you should drink
your piss on a Sunday
morning. I'm saying like-
- If only they had giant tortoise shell.
(Joey and Garnt laughing) I
have one liter of... (laughs)
- That's what I was saying.
I'm going on a desert island,
I'm hoping it's the one desert island
that has the last remaining
like giant tortoise.
- That question of like what do you bring
to a desert island?
(all laughing)
One giant tortoise, please.
- A family of giant
tortoises that I can breed
so I can sustain myself forever.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Oh my God.
- Have you guys seen
like, "Nathan For You,"
like talk about piss drinking.
Have you guys ever seen "Nathan For You?"
- No.
- Oh, is this the one where he like tries
to fix their business or something?
- Yeah, yeah.
There's one where he tries
to fix their business.
- Oh, I've heard this is really good.
I really wanna watch it.
- It is a really good show.
So, it's kind of like, so it's,
I dunno what the actor's name,
but the character he plays is Nathan
and he tries to fix these businesses.
- Yeah.
- With like the most like out-of-the-box,
dumb idea possible, right?
- Mm.
- And like part of like
what makes the show funny
is him pitching these ideas,
to these failing businesses.
So, it's kinda like, you know,
like what Sasha Baron Cohen does.
Like he puts people in
ridiculous situations
and sees how they react, right?
And I think (laughs) like
one of my favorite TV moments
of all time was possibly
like the only time
that I've seen him like break character
or almost break character.
'Cause he was talking to this guy,
this old guy.
And he randomly,
I can't remember the exact
context of the conversation,
but he randomly brings up like
a jar of piss or something.
Right? Just to try and shock the guy.
- Okay.
- And the guy goes,
"Oh yeah. Like I drink jar
of pisses all the time."
(all laughing)
And you could tell like it
was like the most unscripted,
amazing piece of moment
on TV I've ever seen,
where Nathan's like,
"What did you just say?"
He's just like, "Yeah.
Like sometimes like I have
like my grandchildren's piss
just lying about,
sometimes I take a swig."
And (laughing) you need
to watch this clip,
like 'cause in context,
it's hilarious, outta
context, it's still hilarious.
It's the only time this
like Nathan comes close
to like breaking character
because he's hearing
something so shocking.
- Why is it that immediately in my head,
I was like, drinking your own piss.
Ha ha, hilarious.
Drinking your children's piss,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
Like as if it's like worse.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- You're just completing
the cycle of life.
They came outta you.
- [Joey] You're going back in.
(all laughing)
- You're taking it back.
- It's so fucked up.
- That's disgusting.
- [Joey] Oh gross.
- Okay. So, you go to a desert island?
- Yeah.
- All right? You're on the
plane that Wilson's on.
- Mm.
- And what three items
do you bring to that?
- I don't think his
name was Wilson, was it?
- No, but the ball's name was Wilson.
That was on the plane.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tom Hanks' character, right?
Yeah.
- No, that wasn't his name.
It was the ball's name.
(Garnt coughing)
- Yeah, I know
but you're talking about
Tom Hanks' character, right?
- Who cares about him.
Wilson was the star.
(Joey laughing)
- So, you can bring
three items to survive.
What do you bring?
- Firestarter. (sniggers)
Come on, come on.
- No.
- [Garnt] What?
- That's a waste of an item.
- The waste of an item?
- Learn there, learn there.
- What if, okay-
- We're not counting
giant tortoise, right?
- Okay. You can't bring a giant tortoise.
That's it, that's finite, Garnt.
That's gonna run out.
- Yeah.
- You should get something more-
- Just like flint or something.
- Yeah.
Well, the flint's gonna
run out too eventually.
- I guess.
- But like okay.
- You shouldn't rely on that.
- You shouldn't.
Okay. Assuming we're going now, right?
Without prior knowledge that
we're gonna be crashing.
- No, you're gonna be going,
like the "Big Brother" or some shit.
You're gonna be sent
to this desert island.
- A tent.
- [Connor] You can take a tent.
- Yeah.
I would take a tent 'cause I'm
not fucking collecting bones
to make a house, fuck that.
- Just collect leaves, right?
Just fashion your own tent.
- I would love to see
you try and build a house
from leaves, dude.
- Okay, okay.
Let's tear these things down at the end
and what are the other two?
- A knife.
- Okay. I think that's valid.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And
a nice book. Oh fuck.
(Garnt laughing)
- A nice book!
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Joey's gonna die day one.
He's gonna actually cut his
tent and then rip the book
in half out of anger.
- And stab myself. (laughs)
- Oh God.
(Joey laughing)
What would you bring, Garnt?
- I would bring a knife.
- Mm.
- A water filter.
- Ooh.
- That can filter salt
water to fresh water.
- Smart, smart.
- Mm.
Hold onto those lines.
- But you can do that with a leaf.
- Huh?
- You can do that with a leaf, right?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Just piss in a snake.
- Just drink your piss.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- And my grandchild's
jar of piss, of course.
(all laughing)
Just in case I run out, just in case.
- I think the one big
thing you'd want to take
is probably a fishing net.
- I thought that as well,
I was like fishing rod
or fishing net.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You'd probably want a
really nice-sized fishing net.
- [Garnt] True.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It'd probably make
your life a lot easier.
- Mm, true, true.
- Or maybe like a fishing spear.
- I feel like a knife you can make,
you could make like a cavemanesque one.
- Like a sharp rock.
- Yeah.
- I feel like you could do that.
And that would do
everything you need to do.
- Maybe, but I feel like a knife
would make things a lot easier.
- [Connor] I think an ax
would be better though.
- But using the knife, you
can make more knives, right?
How are you gonna start
by making the knife
to begin with?
- It's the first knife
that's like gonna be the hardest to make,
unless you're like that one guy on YouTube
who made like a knife out of cardboard
or something like that.
- A knife out of air.
- Damascus leaf knife
or some shit like that.
- Yeah, if you're with
that one Japanese dude
on the island, you'll be
like, "Can I have a knife?"
He's like, "Which one?"
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- What have you got?
- Which genome of tree do you want?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I'll make it.
Can I take a boat?
(all laughing)
Like a really nice yacht?
Like-
- I'll just taking my 6
million dollar mansion.
- Hey, I'm pretty sure some of
these like rich billionaires
would do it.
Why can't I do it?
No one set the scale of items I can bring,
why can't I bring a boat?
- Well, then I'll bring a
jet and get the fuck out.
(all laughing)
- Let's assume it's
like a Minecraft sandbox
where there's no end to the ocean.
- Just goes on forever.
- But I would like the
boat just to be able to-
- I'll just bring a house then with...
I'll just bring a city.
- How are you gonna
bring the house, Garnt?
How are you gonna bring a house?
- On a boat?
- No, you cannot.
You cannot bring a house.
- I'll fucking, I'll fucking-
- What if it's a houseboat?
- I'll fucking float in up-style
with a fucking bunch of balloons, Connor,
like you're just making up
rules as we go along here.
So, I'm just gonna make up rules as well.
- I think it's perfectly
reasonable that you can sail a boat
to a desert island.
I don't see why this is it not fair.
- Well, then you wouldn't
need anything else
'cause you could just fucking
go back to the mainland
with the boat.
- No one said you have
to stay there, Joey.
- Oh my God.
The implication was you had
to stay there and survive.
- Okay, okay.
If I'm staying there and surviving.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- The entire "Magic
Mike" collection on DVD.
(all laughing)
- Never get bored.
- A DVD player.
(all laughing)
And a monitor with a solar panel.
- A laptop with a 3060 in it.
(all laughing)
- My entire gaming set.
- A super computer chip.
'Cause I'll be the only one
who has them apparently.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Oh my God.
- Okay. What would I actually bring?
- [Joey] What would you actually bring?
- Probably a fishing net.
- [Joey] Yeah. You said that. (laughing)
- I know. I know.
I feel like I could make
a spear out of something,
but I also think that is a lot of work
and I'd rather just catch the fish easy.
So, I'm gonna die pretty soon
if I don't get this food.
- [Joey] Yeah, true.
- So, I got a fishing net.
- [Joey And Garnt] Mm-hm.
- A Toyota Prius would be (laughing)
(all laughing)
very economical.
- Take a sick beach shot.
(all laughing)
- Mm, what else? Okay.
What's like the perfect strat?
What's the optimized strat?
A net's pretty good, a knife is shit.
Don't bring a knife.
What a fucking waste.
- I feel like a knife enables you
to make more tools needed to survive.
- Faster, as well.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, fine. So, fishing net and a knife.
- Yeah.
I think fishing net and a
knife is like the go-to.
- Like 'cause you can make a knife,
but like in order to craft a knife,
I feel like that would
take a lot of effort.
But a knife is so useful
that it can help you craft other tools-
- Fast as well.
- I feel like a wind up torch
would be super useful actually.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause like how, let's be honest here.
You're not gonna fucking do that
Indiana Jones shit-
- With the fire?
- It's just not gonna work.
- Why?
- How are you gonna make that?
You don't have oil?
- Huh?
- Those are like oil rags
soaked in like a ball.
- Yeah.
- How are you, you can't
make one of those normally.
- I just sweat onto it.
- [Connor] I don't know
how you'd make that?
How would you make one of those things?
- I'm sure.
Maybe like, I don't know.
There's maybe like some
life hack where you use
like tree sap or some shit, you know.
- Maybe, but like do you
really wanna be fucking around
harvesting tree sap when you could just-
- [Joey] Well, you're
probably gonna be harvesting
other shit, right?
- But like what would you want to be doing
in the nighttime anyway?
Because everyone's stuck
on a desert island.
- Actually.
- It's gonna be pretty dangerous.
- Maybe you see something?
Maybe you wanna-
- Well, if I see something-
- Oh, also rope. Rope actually.
I don't wanna make my own rope.
- Oh, that's true.
- Like a good fucking rope.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(all laughing)
- Like a really good rope.
- But I feel like rope is, I mean,
rope is obviously useful.
If you only have-
- Do you know how to make rope?
- Huh?
- Do you know how to make a rope?
- I don't. But do you
know how to make a fire?
- I can learn how to make a fire.
- Do you know how to make a knife?
- Yeah. I can make a knife.
Start bashing shit together.
(Joey laughing)
- But like, if you can
learn how to make a fire,
you can learn out to make rope, right?
- No, no, no, no.
- [Joey] I feel that's different.
That's different.
- Rope is so hard.
You've gotta make these
like individual strands.
And then, I don't even
know how you do that.
And then you have to start wrapping that.
How do you? Do you know what makes a rope?
- I swear to God-
- What's the base ingredient to a rope?
- A base ingredient.
- What is a rope?
- I swear to God,
I've seen like ropes on
like YouTube tutorials
being made by like massive leaves.
And like-
- It's like tiny strands.
- Tiny strands that they like-
- Braid them together.
- Are you really gonna
want to like, you know,
rely on that though?
Like and then when it breaks,
like fuck sake. (muttering)
- What if the rope you bring breaks?
- How would you break a rope, Garnt?
- With a knife.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Why would you be doing that?
- What do you mean, how
do you break a rope?
How does any rope break?
When you use it a lot,
sometimes it breaks.
- You must be trying really
hard to break this rope.
- How much rope are we talking about?
- Like as much rope as you want.
- Give me a length. Like roughly.
- An infinite amount of rope. (laughing)
- You're gonna have an
infinite amount of rope.
- Well, then I'll bring an
infinite amount of knives.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- You can, what is more
than one knife gonna do?
- I will tie the rope on one side
of like the fucking city I'm leaving from.
And then I'll fucking...
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I'll just like rope myself
back out, like what?
- Garnt, you could barely
cycle across the (indistinct).
How are you gonna pull
yourself back via rope?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
(Garnt sighs)
- I dunno.
I feel like I would be
interested to do like,
not a complete like a desert
island survival special.
- We should do this.
- We should do a survival-
- Where we take the items that we said,
I'll take a rope, a
fishing net and a knife.
And you can take, what was it?
- Ah, rope. No, not rope.
A knife.
- [Ashley] It was knife,
tent, and a nice book.
- That's right. (laughs)
Knife, tent and a nice book.
- I tell you what you should've gone for,
you should've gone with take nothing.
'Cause he's an idiot.
- [Ashley] Water filter for salt water.
And you didn't mention the last one.
- I said Firestarter.
- [Ashley] Firestarter?
- Firestarter.
- Yes, yes. That's what I would take.
(Joey laughing)
- What would you use to
start the fire though
with the firestarter?
- What do you mean?
- Because usually firestarters work
because you already have like
a preexisting light, right?
So, where are you gonna get that from?
- Well, like,
there's like firestarters kits available
that make it easier to start a fire.
- Right.
- Than, you know,
using the raw materials there.
- Right.
- But getting that initial
spark is the hard part, right?
- Right.
- I mean, have you guys
ever made a fire before?
- Once.
- Yeah. Once.
- When?
- Like ages ago.
- I did the fucking stick.
- Yeah, I did the rope one.
- Stick one.
- Yeah, I did the rope and the stick-
- Where'd you learn how to do that?
- When we had like those
like, not scout things, but-
- At like school camp thing.
- Yeah, like a camping thing.
- I did it, yeah.
- I never got taught
this in school at all.
Like I never had like a
fucking like a survival.
- If you had rope, Garnt,
you could make that fire a lot easier.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- How much rope are we talking?
How thick is this rope?
- I would probably side with a
thicker rope though actually.
So, it wouldn't work.
But you could also,
the good thing about
rope is that you could,
let's say if you had a really long rope,
just cut of piece and
then start peeling off
the individual strands
that make the thick rope.
And then you got a small rope.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Now, Shaq, he did this.
- He did this.
- This is just three idiots talking
about surviving on a des-
Three idiots with zero survival knowledge
talk about surviving on a desert island.
- Now, I just wanna do a video
where we should just try do it.
- Would you move into a house you know
someone died in?
- No.
- Yeah.
I mean, if it's a fucking steal.
- Well, okay, hold on. It depends.
How did they die?
Because if they died
from like natural causes.
Yeah, sure.
- Oh my God.
- But if it's like a
brutal murder, then no.
- Okay. Well, why though?
Why?
- It is literally all bone.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
What the fuck?
That looks like a dark souls dungeon.
- [Garnt] That (laughs) is literally
where the final boss lays.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- That's fucking horrific.
- [Garnt] That's the end
game in Elden Ring, man.
Jesus Christ.
- I didn't imagine the skulls
being a part of the equation.
I thought it was just like
bones, tibias and shit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Fucking hell.
- Like so, you would
happily move into a house
where someone got murdered?
- Oh God, yeah.
- [Garnt] Really?
- If I'm getting a deal on this. Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'll be at the fucking meeting with them
being like, "Oh, I dunno,
10% off is a little.
Ooh, someone did die?
Maybe 15, 20% off?" (inhaling)
- How low would you be willing to go?
Like how much would you negotiate down
if you knew someone
had died in this house?
- I'd try at least get a third off.
- 'Cause like that's
actually a pretty big thing
in Japan, isn't it?
Not people getting brutally murdered,
but like houses where people
have died of natural causes.
- Listen, Garnt, in this
market, you can't be picky.
You gotta take what you
can get if it's a steal.
- [Garnt] That is true.
That is true. That is true.
- I'll be like, "Who died in here?
Oh, yeah? Great. Yeah, yeah.
I'm moving in now, is that all right?"
- There's a website actually.
- [Connor] I know, yeah, yeah.
- Which is like a real estate website
where it tells you which
houses are on sale of like,
they call it jiko bukken or
like accident apartments,
where some horrible
accident has happened
and now it's on sale.
- Why would that affect
your view of the apartment
or the house though?
It's like saying,
oh, if someone had used
that swing and died on it,
would you not want to use it?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Well, probably not.
- Is it because they lived there?
Is that what like adds the weight to it?
To me, I don't quite-
- To me, like a house is
just personal, you know?
It's like your personal space.
- It's not a house. It's a home. (laughs)
- That's true. That's true.
- To me, it's like, what
makes a home is the, you know,
the way that you've made it yours, right?
It's like the base walls and
floors don't mean shit to me,
but all my stuff, that's my couch,
that's my TV and I put it there.
That's what makes it me,
well, to me at least.
So, when you know, that's why
when I move into an apartment,
I'm like, "Oh, it's weird.
Someone used to live here."
I'm like, "Oh, it's a box."
- No, no.
I don't think that of like,
someone used to live here,
but like, there's a big
difference between, oh,
someone lived here for 30 years and, oh,
that guy was dead there
a couple years ago.
Like brutally, I'm not okay with that.
- Yeah. I know, it's-
- But if it's not there anymore,
it's not like you moving in and it's like,
don't mind the dead guy,
he's been there for a while.
- Step over him real quick.
- (cross-talking) insurance
should get rid of it. Oh.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Well, it's like, you know,
having your, what was it like?
I guess, it goes back into
partly into like superstition.
- I think it's a how, you know,
I'm not religious, I'm not
very spiritual or anything.
So, I don't have any sort
of connection with death
and people or anything.
I just think it's a steal.
- You just think it's a building.
- It's free real estate.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Literally. Literally, right? Right?
- Free real estate.
- Literally free real estate.
(all laughing)
Originally, like sometimes
when houses were really cheap
in Japan here, I would
go and look, so I'm like,
there's no way this is this cheap.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then you'd go online you would see,
occasionally, that actually
someone had passed in there.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- But you know,
if there's so many apartments where like,
eventually everyone has
to die in an apartment.
- Yeah.
- Or somewhere.
- Or somewhere, yeah.
- Or somewhere, yes.
- But it's also like, that's like,
what if something like a battle
or something happened on a piece of land,
does that affect if you
built something on it?
- Uh.
- What about it?
Is it 'cause it's just a personal feeling
like it's 'cause it's a house?
I'm trying to get like,
because like in Ikebukuro, right?
There's
Sunshine City.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
That was built on like
a POW camp originally.
- Was it actually?
- Yeah.
- I didn't know that.
- That's why they called it Sunshine.
Because they were like let's rebrand it
to make it more happy.
- Well, they weren't gonna
call it... (laughing)
- Prisoner of War prison.
- Prisoner of War City.
POW City.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, like I think
it was like one of the,
that's why they renamed
it to be like Sunshine
'cause they wanted it to be more positive.
- [Joey] Really?
- If you, I believe, can you check this?
- Holy shit, I did not know that.
- I believe, yeah.
I believe that it was a
prisoner of war camp before.
And so you'd think like, I don't go there
and I'm like, "Oh fuck, man. Oh, Jesus."
- I think for me it's more
so about like the recency
of the event, right?
Like 'cause-
- That's fair enough.
- You know-
- So, it's a mixture between
recency plus intimacy.
- Yeah. Recency and intimacy.
Like, you know, I'm sure
there's a ton of land
all around us that was, you know,
where probably soldiers and, you know,
people just died, right?
But it's like, that
happened a very, very, very
long time ago.
Whereas if someone, you know,
just last year got brutally
murdered in this living room
then, yeah, I'd be a
little more uncomfortable.
- It's just not a nice thought
knowing that, I guess,
such an atrocious thing
happened in the very spot that you're-
- Are we talking about
just murder, by the way?
- Yeah. Well, just if someone
died from natural causes,
I'm okay with that.
- My concern would be with
murder or something, right?
It's like, all right, what
if the guy got murdered?
He was involved in like gangs
or something, dealing, right?
I don't want, on their address book,
for it to be like the guy
that we hate lives here.
- [Joey] Yeah. (laughs)
And then they come to my-
- [Joey] Knock knock.
- Yeah. I would probably be
asking a bit more questions.
'Cause obviously I'm not gonna, you know,
if it's something like that
or the person was doing stuff
like that, I'd be like, all right,
this address is probably not
a great address in general.
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
But I mean like I'd be
okay finding staying
there for like temporary or, you know,
just like, you know, you
stay there and, you know,
you find out it happens.
And like that's an interesting story,
but like there's just
something about settling down
or just calling somewhere a home
where something like that has happened
that would just like,
it doesn't make me superstitious.
It's just not a nice thought to have
where somewhere for a place where you
should be completely comfortable.
- Exactly.
- I guess from my permanent home,
I might be a bit different towards it.
- Yeah.
- But towards renting,
I don't, I couldn't care.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Really?
- If it's renting and I'm-
- I wouldn't even be okay
with renting, to be honest.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Even if it's a steal?
- Even if it's a st-
But there's like there's other ways
to get a steal, you know.
- Okay, okay.
- It's just like barter down. (laughing)
- I did, I'd kill for these
prices, literally. (laughing)
- I guess, different
question, but when does-
You move into a new place?
- [Connor] Okay, okay.
- When does it start
actually feel like your home
and not just a place of residence?
If you've ever felt like that, Connor.
- The moment you've like
hit the wall and you've
chipped it and you're like,
"Oh fuck, fucking hell,
that's my problem. Oh fuck!"
- What?
- That's when it hits you.
- That's literally-
- I did that day one.
- Literally day one. (laughing)
- You are just being irresponsible.
- Yeah, I did that day
one 'cause I'm like,
I'm not used to a wall being here.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I chipped a good chunk of like the wood
in the frame of something
when I was moving
one of my chairs.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I was like, "Oh fuck.
I'm not gonna get some my
deposit back now. God dammit."
- It's literally day
one where your furniture
is just a little bit more heavy
than you think it's going to be,
your sofa, you just wanna
move the sofa a little bit.
And it's just like, you're
just trying to nudge it
and then it just, (makes ripping noise)
and it just makes that fucking scratch.
- Yeah, that scratch.
- And you never see it coming.
You're like, I'm going to try my best
to not make this scratch,
but it's always like just a little late.
Like it just slips a little
bit more than you think
it's going to do.
- I think-
- And just leave that scratch.
- I think for me,
the moment where I know I've
like really settled down
is when I am a hundred percent aware
of where everything is in the house.
Because you have that
period where, you know,
you're first moving in,
you're putting shit away in like cabinets
and, you know, everything.
And then for a while you're like,
fuck, where was that thing again?
And you just like look
all around the house
because you dunno where it is.
But the moment where you're
like, (thumb clicking)
I know exactly where that
really specific thing is.
I feel that's when it's like.
- Do you know what it is for me?
It's really weird for me.
For me, it's when I can
switch on and off the lights
without having to look at
them or try to find them,
you know what I mean?
Like you move into a new
house and you just like,
where's the fucking light switch?
Where's the fucking light switch?
And then you live there
for like a week or two
and then you can like
fucking ultra-instinct
this thing, you know?
Like what-
- So, when you enter a room, you just...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Right? Especially like
if it's the living room
and like there's different
switches depending on which part
of the living room and like you live there
for long enough, and like, to me,
a home is when I want to
turn on that exact light.
I know the exact switch
that I have to flick to turn
on that exact light.
- Yeah.
- It's so weird for me
because I've never been a guy who's like
decorated his house a lot.
It's weird, right?
My room's always been like really bare.
It's like a proper engineering room,
which is, I buy everything
exactly what I need to get
whatever I need done, right?
I need a desk, I need a
computer, I need a chair.
- So basically, you don't
buy nonfunctional things?
- I didn't until I moved to Japan.
And then I realized how weird it is.
So, I was like, I feel like
Mark Zuckerberg, you know,
I was like-
- I was the same.
- Yeah, I was like, I need to
add personality to this room.
I need to buy stuff to like
fill this room up, you know?
- I've always been that person
where even when I was back at home
where I'm like if I see
an empty piece on my wall,
I'm just like, I can fill
that up to something.
- [Connor] Ah, no, no, no, no, no.
- Whether that's a poster
or a calendar or anything
that I can.
- I didn't decorate my walls until JoJo.
- Really?
- Yeah, if you go look at my first videos.
- Yeah.
- For JoJo, so, my walls are like,
it's like a scientific experiment room.
It's like depressing.
(Joey laughing)
And JoJo changed them.
- I guess it's because like, I
guess before moving to Japan,
the reason I never decorated anywhere
was because I'd always
think about the moment
where I would have to
move out of that place.
- Right.
- And that, the thought of
having to like pack things up
and just take everything down,
that seemed like such a...
Such a hassle
That I was just like,
I'm going to remove
the hassle from myself,
even though that's like years away
from when I need to move out.
- Right, right.
- And then I just never
ended up decorating my room.
And then I remember like the only reason
I started decorating it was
because I was on camera more so,
(Joey laughing) so it would
look weird if there was nothing
in the background and that
was literally the only reason.
- Yeah, I guess if you're not on camera,
then there's no need, right?
Yeah, that makes sense.
- But, but I guess, I'm
wondering what it would be like
when you actually have
your own personal home
that you're gonna, I guess,
your permanent residence,
that you know you're
gonna stay in for like,
I guess, years and years, right?
- I'm putting a big
fucking hole in the wall
(Garnt laughing)
because I finally can.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Yeah, right?
- Because I can't in my current place.
- You know, I wonder what the feeling
is of being like a true homeowner.
- Yeah.
- And just like being
able to do-
- I just wanna get to that point
where I'm like, you know
what? I don't need this wall.
(Garnt laughing)
- Entire wall, take it down.
Just do it.
- That's just like, I look at that
and I'm just like, that is the end game.
- That's the end game.
- That is the end game.
- If I can do that, where I'm like, wait,
I don't need permission
to take down this wall,
I just do it?
- Like, right on, like in university
you fucking needed permission
to fucking put posters up.
And like the type of blue
tack you use, you know?
(Joey laughing)
And like go from that to
like breaking down a wall
is just like so alien to me.
- It's like, you know what?
I want another room. (laughing)
Give me another room.
That's what I want.
- Gimme another room. Yeah.
Well, let's just make these two rooms
into one massive room.
(Joey laughing)
Like that just sounds so cool to me.
- I want a bunker, that's what I want.
That's the end game for me.
- I want a church of made out of bones.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- [Joey] In my backyard.
- Well, luckily for me,
there's just one ready for purchase.
(Joey laughing)
Does the price get dropped for that?
That's a lot of deaths on that wall.
(Joey laughing)
- I feel-
- A house made out of bones?
- I feel like at that point,
it's just like an
aesthetic choice, you know?
- Yeah.
- So, you kill one person
in a house, suddenly, no.
You kill 50 people, oh,
now it's an attraction.
Oh, okay.
- [Joey] Now it's cool.
- All right, I see how it is.
(all laughing)
So, what I'm hearing is,
you shouldn't stop at one.
You should go the full...
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Fully commit.
- Profitable to be a serial killer.
(all laughing)
- [Connor] Well, it is. (chuckles)
Here's the idea, right?
You're done, right?
You wanna make money,
you wanna be comfortable.
First of all, step one,
become a serial killer.
Step two, profit because
you go to prison, right?
- [Joey] Right.
- You never have to pay
for a thing ever again.
No taxes, nothing, right?
And then now Netflix ringing you up.
"We wanna make a true crime doccie."
Ah, ooh, six figures at per episode.
(all laughing)
- You're just living like Biscuit Oliva.
- Yeah, yeah, you would be.
You'd be the king of the prison.
- So, I don't have to pay rent.
- What do you want from the prison store?
Oh, you want four packs of ramen?
I'll get it for you.
(Joey laughing)
Clean my bum.
- You'd just be in prison.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- Maybe you're into that?
- That's the slight
downside to that, right?
- Slight downside.
(all laughing)
- It's just like a bunker,
isn't it? (chuckling)
- But you'll be rich. (laughing)
In ramen.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Do you ever wanna take on a DIY project?
- Oh yeah. I'd love to.
- I'd love to.
- It's one of those things
that I definitely, definitely,
definitely, when I work less in future-
- [Joey] Mm-hm, yeah.
- And I get my own place,
is that I'm gonna have a lot of fun.
- You're like half retired.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Definitely have a lot fun doing it.
- It's just like-
- You get the mate over and you're like,
"Do you think this is a good idea?"
And he's like, "Let's
give it a go, Connor."
- What's the one thing
you want to build or like-
- Shed for sure.
- Shed?
- Just number one.
- You wanna build a shed?
- I wanna build a shed.
- Yeah, yeah.
I thought about building a shed
at my current place. (laughing)
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Just 'cause I have
a lot of space, but
like, yeah, build. Yeah.
Shed, I don't know?
What is it about building
a shed that it's like,
yeah, I'm a man?
- It's like the tutorial
level into like building shit.
- Or like a table?
I think that's the tutorial level.
- That's the tutorial level.
- Like a work table.
- Yeah.
- Building a work table
where you can do other DIYs.
- Building a shed is just
like the easy version
of building a bunker, you know?
It's like not a tree house.
You don't have to worry about gravity.
It's not underground.
It's just in your garden, right?
- Just sitting there.
- It's just sitting there.
- Yeah, I mean like
right now it's annoying.
'Cause like I'll have a problem, I'm like,
man, if I just had a saw and some wood,
I could like make this
thing in my apartment
just work easier.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Would you ever want a man cave?
- I guess that's the shed, right?
- Yeah. For sure.
- Yeah.
- What is it about?
I dunno, but like there's
just something primal
about just having your
own like man cave, right?
I dunno why, but every guy I know-
- No ladies allowed.
(Garnt laughing)
- It's just a shed with like
a Time Crisis machine in it.
It's like, "Boys, come over."
- It's like pool table, dartboard.
Time Crisis machine.
- Time Crisis machine.
- That's all I need.
- Has to be Time Crisis,
one or two, maybe three.
Anything-
- I don't wanna be that guy who
assumes things about genders
and stuff like that, but like
do girls want a girl cave?
Like I'm genuinely curious
because every girl-
- A girl cave. (laughing)
- Garnt, the house is the girl cave.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
That's why we build a man cave
because the girl doesn't
let you build the man cave
in the house.
- As men, we can't comprehend
more than one room.
- Yeah.
- That's true.
- We're like one room.
- We don't need more than one room.
- Yeah, true.
We're like, I wanna be able
to play Osu! on 4k Dolby Atmos
in the shed and have a beer machine.
That's what I want.
I don't care about how it looks.
It's my thing.
Whereas I think, generally,
you know, I'm not assuming,
that normal, I think,
women like taking care
of the whole space, don't they?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- We're messy.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- I don't know if I'm correct,
I might've just said something
that's (cross-talking)
if I did-
- Also again, like in my opinion,
like just because I'm
this, men just in general,
just don't have a sense of interior design
like a lot of ladies do.
- But then you meet some guys who do.
- You meet some guys who
are just like wizards
and you're like how-
- But you're saying generally.
- Generally speaking.
I think the general consensus
is that a lot of guys
are just like, put up poster here.
And then put up something
that doesn't completely match over here.
Whereas, you know,
a lot of ladies like,
no, balance, theming.
- That was probably one of the things
I hated most about moving,
was having to figure out
where everything goes.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I didn't like that.
- Because every time you
try to do it yourself,
you just like, no-
- I just did my office.
And then I was like, I dunno
what to do for the rest.
- Yeah, I just did my
office as well. (laughing)
- I just did my office as well.
(Joey laughing)
And even my office was like
fucking difficult as shit
to figure out.
- Right.
- I thought I had like the perfect setup
and then I put everything in place
and then it just looked shit.
(Joey laughing) It looked
shit. It looked shit.
And I had to like do real life Sims
where I was like placing
things in different spaces.
- Moving it around.
- But unfortunately,
I couldn't just click on a button,
I had to like physically move
this fucking heavy-ass desk
like around my room until I found a place
that I felt comfortable with.
And I wish I could just
like see in my mind's eye
where would look the best.
But like my imagination
just sucks when it comes
to interior design.
- I wish I had that like
overview camera, you know,
of the room where I could
just see the entire thing.
I'm like, yes, I know exactly
what this is gonna look like.
- Also, like I just hate making decisions.
I don't like, I dunno if that's the thing,
but like the thing-
- Decision fatigue.
- This is why you would fail
in the zombie apocalypse.
(Joey laughing)
- Probably, I just-
- Which weapon?
- I just want someone to
make all my decisions for me.
You know? Like-
- Oh my God.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Goo, goo, ga, ga, Garnt. (laughing)
Change my diapers, Sydney.
- I just want to exist comfortably.
Like I want someone to
make the decisions for me.
As long as I can just exist comfortably.
It's a good life.
- There's a good place for
that, I think it's called jail.
- [Connor] Prison.
(all laughing)
Honestly, you're bashing prison,
it kinda sounds like you like it.
- Yeah, they make all the
decisions for you there.
- They tell you when to eat.
They tell you when you
can go and exercise.
Look, Garnt, they kinda
sound like you might like it.
- But it's not-
- I think you would do the best in prison
out of the three of us.
- Why? (Joey laughing)
- 'Cause you'd be in the fucking-
- How do you do well in prison?
- You'd be sitting in the fucking corner
having a great time watching
like "Kitchen Nightmares"
in your head for the
third time, obviously.
Me and Joey would be like going crazy.
- Absolutely.
- That's probably
true actually.
- Yeah.
- Garnt would be totally chill in prison.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You'd be friends with everyone.
'Cause no one can hate you.
- Yeah.
You'd have no decision fatigue either
'cause everything's been selected for you.
(all laughing)
- I don't have to worry
about interior design.
- Literally, the most
stress-free lifestyle.
- Consider, consider? (laughing)
- It's the knowledge that if
I wanted to, I could leave.
If I wanted to, I could make a decision
and have my own freedom.
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] I see, I see.
- So, maybe like a make-believe prison.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- So, Garnt wants prison,
but he can leave when he wants.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So, like a rehab?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Like a hospital?
- Like a hospital.
(all laughing)
Like a mental asylum?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- If you're well enough, you can leave.
- No, you can't leave
a mental asylum, Garnt.
- I'd be the easiest like
grandparent to take care of,
you know, I would just like just leave-
- Old folks home.
- Yeah. An old folks home.
Just leave me there.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Future child, please do not
take this clip out of context.
Please take care of me.
This is just young me
talking shit with the boys.
Please do not leave me
in an old folks home.
- I can just imagine you go
to visit your grandparents
in this old person's home.
And then just like next to
your 70-year-old granddad
is 30-year-old Garnt, playing Solitaire.
Like (chuckles) Garnt's
like, "I love it here.
It's amazing. They take care of me."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Have you ever thought
about it? Because, so like-
- No.
- Have you ever thought about-
- No never thought.
- Okay.
So, you have kids, right?
- Mm.
- I'm sure every parent
goes through this phase.
You have kids.
You want them to take care
of you when you're older
because I don't know like many people
who want to be in a
retirement home, right?
You want to be close to
your kids as possible.
- Right?
- How'd you trick them
into doing that? (laughing)
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
How would you convince
your kids to do that?
- Well, this is where the past 40 years
will matter, Garnt.
Whether or not you
treated your kids right.
- Yeah, right, right.
- Did you raise a piece of shit?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I think it's all about
how you raised them.
- How were you raised?
Were you raised-
- I wasn't. I was left to
fend for myself, Garnt.
On a desert island.
- The wolves were my parents.
- Because for me, right.
(Connor howling)
(all laughing)
For you, guys, you've got family, right?
You got brothers and sisters.
You can spread the load, right?
For me, I'm like an only child.
So, like my parents are
like all or nothing for me.
They're like praying that I
don't just wake up one day
and I'm just like, "Mom, dad,
I guess you're going in
the retirement home today."
God, they're probably sweating
watching this right now
actually. (laughing)
- Oh shit, he's considering.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Depends, you know?
'Cause what if it's like different, right?
If you are like 40, 50.
- [Garnt] Mm.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You probably have a lot
more like time and resources
to be able to help.
If you're 20, 25, 30.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know, you're barely being able
to take care of yourself.
- Also think about like, you know,
if you live near your parents.
Like you could be, you know,
you could be on the
other side of the planet.
And it's like, if they can't
take care of themselves,
then who's going to?
- Yeah, 'cause-
- Retirement home.
- We're, unfortunately, we are three guys
who are living like very, very
far away from our parents.
- Exactly.
- But like, yeah.
I think like we're like the exceptions.
- That's why my sister
lives near my parents.
So, all the work goes to her.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- That's what I'm saying.
- Do your parents need help already?
- Having siblings is a cheat code, man.
That's all I'm saying, man. Like-
- I'm like, "Sister, good
luck. See you later."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Teleport away.
- You were the first one
to leave the house like-
- So, now my sister's like,
"Oh fuck, I can't leave now."
- Totally raising another
kid wasn't so annoying.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
We'd all have like 15 kids.
All right, well, Garnt, I'm
glad to know that your parents
are on a one way street
to a retirement home.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Hope you've enjoyed this
episode of Trash Taste.
- Hey, you know who doesn't
have decision fatigue though?
Our patrons.
- [Connor] Wow.
- Because they decide to support us.
- Yeah, I was gonna say, I was gonna say!
- Hell yeah.
- Those are the real Gs.
- Real Gs, but, hey,
if you want to support
the boys as well, then make
sure you go to our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes in the subheader.
And if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
- Yeah.
- Well, yeah, well, thanks for watching.
- That's been the survivalist
episode of Trash Taste.
- [Joey] What's a survivalist?
I don't even know.
- [Garnt] I think it was like-
- [Connor] It was survival episode.
- This was a survival
episode for fucking idiots.
Drink piss.
(Joey laughing)
- This is one of our best
ones I think in a while.
I had fun.
- A lot of fun.
- Drink piss or not?
- Yeah. (laughs)
Never drink piss or always drink piss.
- That's the real question,
do you drink piss to survive or not?
That's the only piece of
knowledge I need to know
that I'm missing right now.
- Let us know in the comments
if you've drank piss.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Bye. Bye.
- [Garnt] Bye.
- [Joey] Bye.
(laid-back music)